The Path of Prayer
cue-2
by Samuel Chadwick.
cue-3
Originally published in 1903.
cue-4
Audiobook produced and copyrighted by
scrollreader.com.
cue-5
Chapter One:
cue-6
The Sign of Prayer.
cue-7
All religions include prayer.
cue-8
God and prayer belong together.
cue-9
Belief in God naturally leads to belief in
prayer. These ideas may be rough
cue-10
or even misguided in some early or pagan
cultures,
cue-11
but they are part of the shared instincts
of humanity.
cue-12
The Old Testament speaks often about
prayer.
cue-13
It gives many commands and encouragements
to pray.
cue-14
Its stories of rescue, victory,
experience, and vision all
cue-15
show the power of earnest prayer. In the
life of our Lord, every
cue-16
major moment was connected with special
times of prayer. His teaching
cue-17
gives strong promises to those who pray.
cue-18
He explained how prayer works, but he did
not try to explain its mystery.
cue-19
For him, prayer was not a problem to
solve. The two parables he told
cue-20
about prayer can be difficult for some.
cue-21
It may seem strange to compare God to an
unjust judge or an unwilling
cue-22
friend,
cue-23
but God is not like them.
cue-24
These parables are not meant to describe
God's character, but to show the value of
cue-25
persistence in prayer.
cue-26
The foundation of prayer is our
relationship as children of God. Prayer is
cue-27
possible and reasonable because it is
like a child speaking to a
cue-28
father. It is natural for a child to ask
and right for a
cue-29
father to listen.
cue-30
If human parents, though imperfect, give
good gifts to their children, how
cue-31
much more will our heavenly Father give
good things to those who ask Him?
cue-32
There are many questions about prayer, but
they can't be solved by thinking alone.
cue-33
They are answered through the act of
praying itself.
cue-34
Prayer is something we experience, and
throughout history, those who have prayed
cue-35
testify that God hears and answers His
children.
cue-36
What God thinks about prayer.
cue-37
God's thoughts are not like human
thoughts, and His ways are not like ours.
cue-38
His ways are higher, just as the heavens
are higher than the earth.
cue-39
God has made His thoughts and ways known
through His Word and through His
cue-40
Son.
cue-41
He reveals Himself through real
experiences and through events in the
cue-42
lives of people and in history. He has not
explained His thoughts
cue-43
in abstract theories, but has shown them
through life and has taught His ways
cue-44
through commands, principles, and
examples.
cue-45
There is a clear example that shows what
God thinks about prayer.
cue-46
His view of prayer is seen in every
command to pray,
cue-47
every rule about prayer, every promise
connected to prayer, and every
cue-48
example where prayer is answered.
cue-49
Each part helps us understand the whole.
cue-50
Yet in Scripture, each subject is shown
most fully in a particular example.
cue-51
In the conversion of Saul of Tarsus, we
see a special and clear picture of God's
cue-52
mind about prayer.
cue-53
In that event, there are three people
involved: the one who prays, God who
cue-54
hears, and the person through whom the
answer comes.
cue-55
God is at the center.
cue-56
Prayer is made to Him, understood through
Him, and answered by Him.
cue-57
God speaks of prayer with a sense of
wonder.
cue-58
Look, he is praying.
cue-59
This is human language, and though it is
limited, it still points to something
cue-60
real in God. Does God feel wonder? Can He
experience
cue-61
surprise or amazement?
cue-62
Are there things that are wonderful to
Him? This is how God speaks, and
cue-63
it shows that prayer is deeply precious to
Him.
cue-64
It seems that one of the greatest things
in God's universe is a person who prays.
cue-65
There is only one thing more surprising,
cue-66
that people, knowing this, still do not
pray.
cue-67
Look,
cue-68
in that word there is wonder, joy, and
delight.
cue-69
In God's view, prayer is greater than the
wonders of the heavens, more glorious than
cue-70
the mysteries of the earth, and more
powerful than all the forces of creation.
cue-71
God sees prayer as the sign of all that
happened to Saul of Tarsus on the
cue-72
Damascus Road.
cue-73
The event can be described in different
ways.
cue-74
To the churches in Judea, it was a
conversion that turned their greatest
cue-75
enemy into a preacher.
cue-76
Paul himself describes it this way when
writing to the Galatians.
cue-77
He went into the regions of Syria and
Cilicia and was not personally known
cue-78
to the churches in Judea,
cue-79
but they had heard that the one who once
persecuted them was now preaching the
cue-80
faith he had tried to destroy.
cue-81
Because of this, they glorified God.
cue-82
This was a true conversion that came from
a powerful experience.
cue-83
What was that experience?
cue-84
Paul explains that God was pleased to
reveal His Son in him.
cue-85
That is what the Damascus Road meant to
him. But when God speaks of
cue-86
it, He sums it all up in one simple
statement.
cue-87
Look, he is praying.
cue-88
That is what it meant to God, and that is
what it always means to Him.
cue-89
Prayer is the sign, the proof, and the
measure of grace.
cue-90
When God works in a person and brings them
into His family as His children, the
cue-91
result is this.
cue-92
They begin to praySaul of Tarsus had
prayed all his life, but it
cue-93
was not until that moment that he truly
prayed in the way God understands prayer.
cue-94
The words of a simple children's hymn also
apply to adults.
cue-95
I often say my prayers, but do I really
pray?
cue-96
Prayer belongs to those who are God's
children, and it shows that they are His
cue-97
children.
cue-98
It seems that God divides people in a very
simple way,
cue-99
those who pray and those who do not.
cue-100
It is a simple test, but it is clear and
decisive.
cue-101
The way God answers prayer.
cue-102
God answers with joy.
cue-103
There is a tone of delight in His words to
Ananias, like the joy seen in the
cue-104
parables of the lost sheep, the lost coin,
and the lost son.
cue-105
Look, he is praying shows that there is
joy in the heart of God the Father when
cue-106
His lost children begin to pray.
cue-107
God answers in a way that fits who He is.
cue-108
Ananias may hesitate or question, but God
does not hesitate with people.
cue-109
God is ready to answer when a person
reaches out to Him, and His response is
cue-110
always greater than the cry that calls to
Him.
cue-111
God's answer to Saul of Tarsus had two
parts.
cue-112
He gave him a vision and sent him a
messenger,
cue-113
a vision and a man that matched each
other.
cue-114
This is often God's way.
cue-115
First, He gives assurance, and then He
confirms it.
cue-116
This is the kind of prayer that trusts God
and does not fail.
cue-117
God's servants work together with Him in
the work of prayer.
cue-118
This is part of the mystery of how God and
people cooperate. The Lord goes ahead
cue-119
of the person He sends.
cue-120
Saul was ready and waiting for the man he
had already seen in a vision from God,
cue-121
and Ananias found him prepared and ready.
cue-122
God gave Ananias the sign of prayer as
proof of grace.
cue-123
It was His own sign, and it is still the
sign He gives today.
cue-124
Is there any clearer proof that a person
belongs to God than that they truly pray?
cue-125
Of Elijah, it is said that he prayed
earnestly.
cue-126
Some people are said to live in an
atmosphere of devotion, but it is one
cue-127
thing to be around prayer and another to
truly pray with sincerity.
cue-128
Finney once attended a weekly prayer
meeting where many prayers were spoken,
cue-129
yet no answers came.
cue-130
Mueller prayed, and answers followed.
cue-131
That is why people recognized him as a man
of God.
cue-132
When I was a small child, about six or
seven years old,
cue-133
I was sent to a neighbor's house one
morning.
cue-134
I knocked, opened the door, and stepped
inside.
cue-135
There, by a chair with an open Bible, Mrs.
Davenport was kneeling in prayer.
cue-136
She did not notice me.
cue-137
I stood quietly for a moment in deep
respect, then gently left and closed
cue-138
the door. Many years have passed since
that day, but
cue-139
I have never forgotten it.
cue-140
From that moment on, I knew that Mrs.
Davenport was a true servant of God
cue-141
because she prayed.
cue-142
This is God's sure sign, and even the
world recognizes it as clear
cue-143
proof.
cue-144
Prayer changed everything for Saul of
Tarsus, and it always makes a
cue-145
difference. It brought him a new assurance
of God, a stronger faith,
cue-146
fellowship with God's people, healing, a
new calling, a new
cue-147
inheritance, and new power.
cue-148
Prayer changes things. It makes all things
possible
cue-149
because it connects the one who prays with
God's unlimited power.
cue-150
Do we truly pray? Do we mean what we say
when we pray? Does God place His
cue-151
approval on our prayers?
cue-152
Lord, teach us to pray.
cue-153
Prayer is the voice of a humble sinner
turning back to God, while angels
cue-154
rejoice and say, "Look, he is praying."
cue-155
It is the very breath of a Christian, the
air they are meant to live in,
cue-156
their word of hope even at death,
cue-157
and with prayer they enter heaven.
cue-158
Chapter Two:
cue-159
Learning to Pray.
cue-160
Can prayer be learned?
cue-161
Isn't true prayer meant to flow freely
from the spirit?
cue-162
John the Baptist gave his disciples a set
form of prayer,
cue-163
and the disciples of Jesus also asked him
to teach them to pray.
cue-164
They did not often ask him for things, and
when they did, they were often
cue-165
mistaken.
cue-166
Yet here they asked for something right.
cue-167
Why did they ask?
cue-168
Seeing Jesus pray stirred in them a desire
to pray as he did. But when
cue-169
they tried, they realized they did not
know how. They felt the
cue-170
need for some form to help them express
what was in their hearts to God.
cue-171
They even pointed to the example of John.
cue-172
People still do this, looking for forms
instead of seeking a living spirit
cue-173
of prayer.
cue-174
Forms are easier than praying from the
heart.
cue-175
Repeating prayers on beads is easier than
speaking freely and honestly to
cue-176
God. A prayer book can help those who
struggle to find words.
cue-177
Such prayers can be sincere, and they can
truly help devotion.
cue-178
In fact, this kind of prayer often needs
to be learned from others.
cue-179
But this kind of prayer is often repeated
without thought.
cue-180
Some repeat set prayers, while others are
unfamiliar with written prayers
cue-181
altogether.
cue-182
Most people begin praying with forms.
cue-183
Many remember the simple, sincere prayers
they learned as children,
cue-184
spoken with reverence and wonder at their
mother's
cue-185
side.Personality in prayer.
cue-186
It is not the prayers of others that make
someone a person of prayer.
cue-187
True prayer, the kind that is effective,
is personal, close, and genuine.
cue-188
Hannah said that she poured out her soul
before God. That is prayer, but
cue-189
it is not the whole of it.
cue-190
Listening and receiving from God are just
as important as speaking.
cue-191
Saul of Tarsus had prayed from his youth,
cue-192
but he did not truly pray until he met the
risen Lord on the Damascus road.
cue-193
From Heaven's point of view, all that had
changed in him was summed up in the words,
cue-194
"Look, he is praying."
cue-195
The secret of Elijah's power in prayer was
that he truly prayed.
cue-196
He did not just say words, he meant them.
cue-197
His whole heart was involved.
cue-198
He deeply desired what he asked for,
cue-199
and he spoke with sincerity and passion.
cue-200
This raises the question, can this kind of
prayer be taught?
cue-201
It is this kind of prayer that is
effective.
cue-202
Mere routine in worship or reading words
written by others without understanding
cue-203
is not pleasing to God and does not help
people. Such prayers become
cue-204
empty repetition. Much prayer, as far as
we can see, seems to have
cue-205
no effect.
cue-206
There may be many prayers offered, but
their value is not in how many there are.
cue-207
Prayer cannot be measured by numbers or by
time.
cue-208
The real issue is not quantity, but depth.
cue-209
Prayer is measured by sincerity and
intensity. Some prayers are full
cue-210
of feeling, yet seem unanswered.
cue-211
At other times, we know we should pray
deeply, but we feel unable to do so.
cue-212
We do not know how to pray.
cue-213
Prayer learned by praying.
cue-214
The only way to learn to pray is by
actually praying. No careful
cue-215
reasoning or theory about prayer has ever
taught a person how to pray.
cue-216
There are many questions about prayer, but
for the one who truly prays, these
cue-217
questions are answered through experience,
through answered prayer, and the joy
cue-218
of knowing God.
cue-219
We do not know what we should pray for as
we ought, and if we wait until we
cue-220
understand everything, we will never
begin.
cue-221
We live by faith, and we walk by faith.
cue-222
As has been observed, we understand very
little about the world around us, about
cue-223
things like water, light, gravity, or
electricity.
cue-224
Yet we still use them every day. Our lack
of full understanding does
cue-225
not stop us from benefiting from them. In
the same way, we learn by
cue-226
doing. We discover through practice.
cue-227
Even if someone knew everything about
prayer in theory, without actually
cue-228
praying, they would never truly learn how
to pray.
cue-229
There have been people who became powerful
in prayer, and they learned how to
cue-230
pray. At one time, they were like others
in their prayer life,
cue-231
but they grew strong with God and saw
answers.
cue-232
In every case, there was a turning point
of God's grace,
cue-233
but it was through continued discipline
and practice that they discovered the
cue-234
secret of spiritual power.
cue-235
They were known as people of God because
they were people of prayer. Some were even
cue-236
given names that reflected this, like
Praying John, Praying Mary,
cue-237
Praying Bramwell, and Praying Hyde.
cue-238
Early Methodists were strong in prayer.
cue-239
Through prayer, they helped bring
spiritual change to England.
cue-240
Through prayer, they fought against evil
and shook the gates of hell and saw God's
cue-241
power at work.
cue-242
How did they learn to pray?
cue-243
They learned by praying often. They did
not just talk about prayer, they prayed.
cue-244
They did not argue about it, they prayed.
cue-245
Trained in prayer.
cue-246
Prayer reaches both extremes.
cue-247
It is so simple that even a child can
pray, and yet so deep that
cue-248
only a childlike heart can truly pray.
cue-249
A well-known hymn by Montgomery expresses
this truth clearly.
cue-250
Prayer is the soul's sincere desire,
cue-251
uttered or unexpressed, the motion of a
hidden fire that trembles in the breast.
cue-252
Prayer is the simplest form of speech that
infant lips can try.
cue-253
Prayer the sublimest strains that reach
the Majesty on high.
cue-254
That is deeply true.
cue-255
A simple cry brings God near.
cue-256
A cry is stronger than carefully crafted
words.
cue-257
The Pharisee prayed only to himself.
cue-258
His prayers stayed stuck in his own pride
and empty thoughts.
cue-259
But the tax collector cried out and was
heard.
cue-260
We are not thinking about quick prayers in
moments of crisis, but about a steady
cue-261
life of prayer.
cue-262
This kind of prayer comes through
training, and no discipline is more
cue-263
demanding.
cue-264
Coleridge said that such prayer is the
highest use of the human heart's strength,
cue-265
requiring the full focus of all a person's
abilities. He believed that
cue-266
most worldly and even learned people are
not able to truly
cue-267
pray. To pray as God desires is the
greatest work a person can
cue-268
do on Earth.
cue-269
Such a life of prayer has a cost. It
requires time.
cue-270
Quick, rushed prayers or repeated words
spoken without thought will never
cue-271
make a person strong in prayer.
cue-272
To become skilled in any craft, people
give many hours each day to
cue-273
practice. In the same way, our Lord rose
early in the morning to
cue-274
pray, and at times, he spent the whole
night in prayer.
cue-275
Those who have been strong in prayer have
given much time to it daily.
cue-276
It may feel difficult to think about such
examples.In our busy lives,
cue-277
we often feel there is no time to pray.
cue-278
But without giving time, real, regular
time, we will never learn.
cue-279
Surely it should be possible to give God
one hour out of each day. At the very
cue-280
least, we can begin by setting aside a
fixed time each day for prayer.
cue-281
We must make a serious decision to learn
how to pray,
cue-282
to pray with all our heart and strength,
with both mind and will,
cue-283
to truly believe that God hears us through
Christ and will act according to His
cue-284
will. This is one of the greatest
achievements of the Christian life on
cue-285
Earth.
cue-286
Teach us to pray, O Lord, we ask you.
cue-287
The praying spirit breathe, the watching
power impart, from all entanglements
cue-288
beneath, call off my anxious heart. My
feeble mind sustain, by
cue-289
worldly thoughts oppressed, appear and bid
me turn again to my eternal rest.
cue-290
When you feel the strain of discipline,
remember these words.
cue-291
Thou art oft most present, Lord, in weak,
distracted prayer.
cue-292
A sinner out of heart with self most often
finds thee there.
cue-293
For prayer that humbles sets the soul from
all delusions free and
cue-294
teaches it how utterly, dear Lord, it
hangs on thee.
cue-295
Chapter Three:
cue-296
Praying in Secret.
cue-297
If prayer is the greatest thing we can do
on Earth, then it requires a discipline
cue-298
that matches its power. The life of prayer
has its own rules and demands.
cue-299
Only those who are determined and steady
in heart will enter into it. Even
cue-300
strong people can become worn out by deep
thinking. Focus takes more
cue-301
effort than physical work.
cue-302
Discipline limits our freedom and trains
the mind to pay attention. It
cue-303
is harder to understand than to simply
act, and quiet meditation can be more
cue-304
demanding than active service.
cue-305
Many people do not pray because of what it
costs.
cue-306
The cost is not mainly in intense moments
of pleading, but in daily faithfulness
cue-307
to prayer.
cue-308
This is the true test of devotion.
cue-309
Nothing in the Christian life is harder to
keep up.
cue-310
Some people dislike the idea that prayer
requires discipline and deep
cue-311
effort. They do not pray this way, and
they would not want their children to
cue-312
beg and cry for what they need.
cue-313
That may be so,
cue-314
but it is clear they do not pray in this
way either.
cue-315
And comparing prayer to children asking
for things does not fully explain
cue-316
it. The life of prayer is a place of
learning for those who truly want to
cue-317
pray.
cue-318
Those who come to learn are disciples.
They place themselves under the guidance
cue-319
of the one they want to learn from,
cue-320
and the first requirement for learning is
a willing and teachable spirit.
cue-321
Our Lord has full authority to teach, and
He is both our example and our
cue-322
teacher.
cue-323
There is no higher authority than Him.
cue-324
When we ask Him to teach us how to pray,
cue-325
we give our minds and hearts to His
instruction,
cue-326
and we commit ourselves to follow Him with
faithful and trusting obedience.
cue-327
What does our Lord teach us about prayer?
cue-328
One of the first things He teaches is that
there should be a special place for
cue-329
prayer.
cue-330
It is true that the whole Earth belongs to
the Lord, and there is no place where
cue-331
prayer cannot be heard.
cue-332
God desires that people pray everywhere.
cue-333
Wherever we are, He is near, not far away.
cue-334
Wherever there is a praying heart, that
place becomes God's sanctuary.
cue-335
Yet Jesus Himself made it a habit to go to
a quiet, private place to pray.
cue-336
He needed times of silence and separation.
cue-337
He taught His disciples the same.
cue-338
When you pray, do not be like the
hypocrites. They love to pray, standing in
cue-339
public places so others can see them.
Truly, they have already
cue-340
received their reward.
cue-341
But when you pray, go into your room,
close the door, and pray to your
cue-342
Father in secret, and your Father, who
sees what is done in secret,
cue-343
will reward you.
cue-344
Prayer may be offered anywhere, but our
Lord teaches us the importance of having a
cue-345
private place set apart for meeting with
God.
cue-346
Why does He insist on a private room and a
closed door?
cue-347
The first reason is that God desires
honesty in prayer.
cue-348
Hypocrites do not pray in secret.
cue-349
Prayers that are only for show need an
audience. They are meant to be heard by
cue-350
people, and their reward is in well-spoken
words, an appearance of
cue-351
sincerity, and a reputation for being
religious.
cue-352
But these things mean nothing to God.
cue-353
They cannot stand in His presence.
cue-354
True prayer is between the soul and God
alone.
cue-355
The silent spaces of the soul.
cue-356
The soul needs quiet and stillness.
cue-357
It is in these silent moments that we
learn to pray. There, alone with
cue-358
God, our Lord tells us to pray to our
Father, who is unseen and who sees
cue-359
all.
cue-360
There is no greater test than being alone.
cue-361
In silence and solitude, many people feel
afraid.
cue-362
The heart often pulls back from being
alone with God, who sees everything.
cue-363
Who can remain in His presence?
cue-364
Who can live with God, who is pure and
without any darkness?
cue-365
To come before Him in this way, hearts
must be pure and conduct must be clean.
cue-366
Yet if most people spent even half an hour
each day alone with God in a quiet
cue-367
place,
cue-368
it would completely change their lives.For
this kind of prayer,
cue-369
every part of the soul must be awake and
alert.
cue-370
When our Lord took Peter, James, and John
with him to pray in a quiet place,
cue-371
they struggled to stay awake.
cue-372
This happened both on the mountain of
glory and in the garden of suffering. Only
cue-373
when they were fully awake did they see
his glory and understand his
cue-374
sorrow. There are quiet places where
people do not speak,
cue-375
yet they still fall asleep.
cue-376
Daydreaming is not meditation, and being
half asleep is not prayer.
cue-377
The secret place of prayer requires the
full attention of both mind and heart.
cue-378
Bless the Lord, O my soul,
cue-379
and all that is within me, bless his holy
name.
cue-380
Just as in praise, so in prayer the whole
person is involved.
cue-381
There is an important difference between
private prayer and prayer with others.
cue-382
Both bring their own kind of blessing, but
they are not the same.
cue-383
Prayer with others is less demanding. The
sense of fellowship gives
cue-384
courage and helps people express
themselves.
cue-385
Praying together can feel supportive, but
it can also lead people to rely on others
cue-386
to do the thinking for them.
cue-387
In private prayer, the soul stands alone
before God.
cue-388
Thoughts are personal, prayers are sincere
and original, and motives are
cue-389
examined.
cue-390
Prayer with others builds fellowship, but
private prayer shapes and strengthens the
cue-391
individual.
cue-392
Who can measure the impact of spending
even one hour a day alone with
cue-393
God?
cue-394
The hill of the Lord.
cue-395
The way into God's presence is not open to
everyone without care.
cue-396
The private place a person enters may be
their own, but it becomes holy because God
cue-397
is there.
cue-398
To someone with a worldly mind, there is
no sense of his presence.
cue-399
It is the person who truly seeks God who
finds him.
cue-400
There are some who do not receive an
answer. Some people cannot truly pray.
cue-401
James says that certain people should not
expect to receive anything from the Lord.
cue-402
Even before Christ taught about prayer,
the psalmist said, "If I hold on to
cue-403
sin in my heart, the Lord will not hear
me,"
cue-404
Psalm sixty-six eighteen.
cue-405
In that private place, there is both
judgment and grace.
cue-406
God sees everything.
cue-407
Sins we have forgotten come back to mind,
and hidden things are fully exposed before
cue-408
him.
cue-409
Yet his throne of grace is there too,
cue-410
or no one would dare come near.
cue-411
Anyone who wants to enter God's presence
and remain there must truly desire
cue-412
him and be willing to live honestly in his
light.
cue-413
Our Lord placed strong emphasis on having
a forgiving spirit.
cue-414
More than anything else, refusing to
forgive from the heart blocks the way into
cue-415
God's presence in prayer.
cue-416
God will not accept any offering until we
are first made right with others.
cue-417
If you are offering your gift at the altar
and remember that your brother has
cue-418
something against you,
cue-419
leave your gift there.
cue-420
First, go and be reconciled to your
brother, and then come and offer your
cue-421
gift. Jesus also connected faith in prayer
with
cue-422
forgiveness.
cue-423
Whatever you ask in prayer, believe that
you have received it, and it will be
cue-424
yours.
cue-425
And when you stand praying, forgive anyone
you have anything against so that your
cue-426
Father in heaven may forgive you. But if
you do not forgive others,
cue-427
your Father will not forgive your sins.
cue-428
Why did he stress forgiveness so strongly?
For the same reason the law and the
cue-429
prophets stressed righteousness.
cue-430
Those who come to a holy God must seek to
be holy. Those who come to a
cue-431
merciful God must show mercy.
cue-432
Anyone who asks for grace must also
believe in it and extend it to
cue-433
others.
cue-434
Thine inner chamber.
cue-435
No one should feel discouraged about
beginning to pray. Just as schools teach
cue-436
step by step, learning to pray also grows
over time.
cue-437
Those who became strong in prayer and
spent hours each day alone with God all
cue-438
began as beginners. They grew little by
little. For our
cue-439
comfort, remember this: the place we enter
is our own inner room,
cue-440
and the God who meets us there is our
Father.
cue-441
Many years ago, a young girl quietly came
into my room where I was staying.
cue-442
She happily talked about the small joys of
her world.
cue-443
When I asked if her father was awake, she
looked at me with bright respect and said,
cue-444
"Oh, my daddy always talks with God in the
drawing room before breakfast."
cue-445
Happy father, happy child,
cue-446
happy God.
cue-447
Chapter four:
cue-448
The inner room and the closed door.
cue-449
But when you pray, go into your room,
close the door, and pray to your Father,
cue-450
who is unseen.
cue-451
Then your Father, who sees what is done in
secret, will reward you.
cue-452
There are two main difficulties when we
try to follow this command.
cue-453
First, many people do not have a true
inner room.
cue-454
There is no place in their lives set apart
for quiet and privacy. They may not
cue-455
have a room of their own, and even if they
did, they often have no free time.
cue-456
Closing a door does not always create real
quiet, either outwardly or
cue-457
inwardly.
cue-458
We know that even locked doors cannot
fully keep things out.Thoughts can
cue-459
pass through more easily than sound, and
the enemy is more subtle than any
cue-460
human invention.
cue-461
Those who have practiced private prayer
know that there are many distractions and
cue-462
struggles waiting at the doorway of the
soul's quiet place.
cue-463
Where shall we find the secret place?
cue-464
My goal is not to give strict
instructions, but to offer simple
cue-465
suggestions. Books on prayer have often
felt more discouraging than helpful to
cue-466
me. They can be too rigid or too
demanding.
cue-467
Instead of helping, they sometimes make
prayer feel harder.
cue-468
I want to speak openly and personally.
cue-469
All my life, I have wanted to learn how to
pray.
cue-470
With that desire, I have tried many
different ways and approaches to prayer,
cue-471
some helpful, some not.
cue-472
Without pride,
cue-473
I want to share in humility what I have
learned.
cue-474
I speak only from my own experience. I do
not judge how others pray,
cue-475
criticize their guidance, or question
their experiences. I will speak
cue-476
plainly, and you can decide for yourself
what is helpful.
cue-477
Let us begin with the problem of privacy.
cue-478
Many followers of Christ have no place
where they can go to pray alone. They
cue-479
live, sleep, and work with others all the
time.
cue-480
They cannot easily get away from people.
cue-481
Does this not show that the doors of God's
house should always be open?
cue-482
One Monday morning, a man who was seeking
God stopped me on the main street after
cue-483
I had preached the day before. There were
several churches nearby, but all of them
cue-484
were locked.
cue-485
We had to go to another church just to
find a quiet place to pray. Church doors
cue-486
should always be open. Even so, that alone
does not fully meet the
cue-487
need.
cue-488
The secret place of prayer should be part
of daily life. It should be something we
cue-489
carry with us, a regular part of how we
live each day.
cue-490
A place must be found where we can meet
with God. A heart that truly longs for
cue-491
Him will find a way.
cue-492
It may be outdoors or in some quiet
corner,
cue-493
but there will be a place set apart
within.
cue-494
If this is not possible, the soul must
learn to create a quiet space within
cue-495
itself,
cue-496
even when others are nearby,
cue-497
and be alone with God.
cue-498
Still, having a private place for prayer
is a great blessing.
cue-499
God desires that people pray everywhere,
cue-500
but His deepest presence is often found in
quiet and lonely places.
cue-501
There, He meets with us closely and
personally,
cue-502
speaking with us as a friend speaks with a
friend.
cue-503
How can we secure the closed door?
cue-504
How can we keep the world out and stop our
minds from wandering?
cue-505
Focusing the mind is difficult in any
task, but it is especially hard in private
cue-506
prayer.
cue-507
There are many distractions, thoughts that
stir the conscience, memories that
cue-508
interrupt, and concerns that press in
during this quiet time.
cue-509
Simple steps can help create outward
quiet.
cue-510
Some people use small signals to avoid
interruption.
cue-511
But even if the room is quiet, the mind
can still wander.
cue-512
Being alone physically is not enough if
our thoughts are scattered.
cue-513
So the real question is how to quiet the
mind and heart.
cue-514
The closed door must also be within us.
cue-515
We must gently turn our attention back to
God again and again
cue-516
and keep our focus on Him.
cue-517
Only then can we truly be alone with Him
in prayer.
cue-518
Attention is a choice of the will.
Concentration is keeping that attention
cue-519
fixed on one thing. The will can be
trained, and the ability to
cue-520
concentrate can grow. A trained mind
learns to focus, to think
cue-521
clearly, and to stay fixed on what
matters. Through patience, the
cue-522
soul is strengthened, and through
discipline, the mind is shaped.
cue-523
God is present in the secret place,
cue-524
so the first step is to recognize that He
is there. Call every
cue-525
part of your mind and body to remember and
become aware of His presence.
cue-526
Hold firmly to this truth.
cue-527
Do not allow distractions, do not give in
to wandering thoughts, and do not let your
cue-528
mind drift.
cue-529
Every part of you must be awake and ready.
The apostles on the mountain were
cue-530
sleepy,
cue-531
but when they fully woke up, they saw His
glory.
cue-532
Daydreaming is not meditation. Drowsiness
is not thinking. Sitting in
cue-533
dull stillness is not prayer.
cue-534
Prayer in the secret place always requires
the full attention of the whole person.
cue-535
Our Lord gave His disciples a pattern for
prayer,
cue-536
and it does not begin with singing or
asking, but with thinking about God.
cue-537
Our Father, who is in heaven, holy is Your
name.
cue-538
This is how many of the great prayers in
the Bible begin.
cue-539
I have found it helpful to start this way.
cue-540
I think with love and wonder about who God
is, His character, His power,
cue-541
His greatness, His grace, and His glory.
cue-542
As I reflect on these things, my heart
begins to grow warm.
cue-543
This focus becomes like a protective wall,
keeping distractions away.
cue-544
That is why prayer in the secret place
often begins with praise and thanksgiving.
cue-545
It is in this place that we begin to see
the glory of the Lord.
cue-546
The Word of God in the Holy Presence.
cue-547
I take no book with me into the secret
place except the Bible. It is my prayer
cue-548
book.I do not use outward aids like a
cross or crucifix. My
cue-549
altar is within, where I meet God.
cue-550
Others may have different ways, and many
people use devotional books, but I do not
cue-551
even take a hymn book with me.
cue-552
I use the Bible by searching its truth,
receiving its promises, and turning its
cue-553
psalms and prayers into my own
thanksgiving and requests.
cue-554
In that quiet place, I do not think about
criticism or analysis,
cue-555
just as I do not analyze my food while
eating.
cue-556
God's Word is more necessary to me than
daily food. It stirs my heart
cue-557
and fills me with deep power.
cue-558
The Word of God teaches us how to pray.
The position of the body should depend on
cue-559
health and comfort. Kneeling is usually
helpful and shows reverence.
cue-560
One friend of mine prefers to sit, placing
an empty chair beside him as a
cue-561
reminder of God's presence.
cue-562
While kneeling is a good habit, each
person must choose what fits their
cue-563
condition of body and soul.
cue-564
Still, it is right that we kneel before
the Lord our Maker.
cue-565
Prayer is more than asking for things, but
even our requests should be guided by
cue-566
the Holy Spirit.
cue-567
I find it helpful to look back over my
daily life in God's presence.
cue-568
It is there that I make my plans.
cue-569
God reveals His pattern for life in His
presence. Thomas Champness
cue-570
used to speak with God each morning about
his work and those he served.
cue-571
God guides us quietly and personally, and
this is best understood in private
cue-572
fellowship with Him. It is there that we
become sure of His will and
cue-573
learn His way.
cue-574
It is also the place of intercession.
cue-575
Here we can speak freely with God about
others. Our family, church,
cue-576
work, friendships, nation, and the world
should all be brought before Him
cue-577
in sincere and trusting prayer. It is
helpful to pray for people one by
cue-578
one. Leaders can pray through their lists
of names, and teachers can do
cue-579
the same for those they guide. Keep a list
of people and needs to
cue-580
remember in prayer.
cue-581
There is no need to tell others what you
tell God. The Father sees, hears,
cue-582
and knows in secret.
cue-583
Leave everything in His hands.
cue-584
God, who is in secret, is our Father.
cue-585
Prayer is like a child speaking to a
loving parent. He knows our needs even
cue-586
before we speak, and He is able to do far
more than we can ask or imagine.
cue-587
So we should pray with confidence and
without doubt.
cue-588
In the secret place, we learn that silence
can be better than speaking,
cue-589
and listening is a vital part of prayer.
cue-590
Those who speak are heard, but those who
listen begin to truly hear
cue-591
God.
cue-592
Of Jesus, it is written in Mark chapter
one, verse thirty-five,
cue-593
"Very early in the morning, while it was
still dark, he got up, went to a
cue-594
quiet place, and prayed."
cue-595
Chapter five:
cue-596
The Word of God and Prayer.
cue-597
The Word of God brings life to the soul
and teaches us how to pray.
cue-598
The psalmist speaks for all who pray when
he says there are times when the soul
cue-599
feels low and weak.
cue-600
"My soul clings to the dust; give me life
according to your word."
cue-601
In such times, he always turns to God's
Word for help and guidance.
cue-602
Paul also connects the Word of God with
prayer. He speaks of
cue-603
taking the sword of the Spirit, which is
the Word of God,
cue-604
and then praying always with all kinds of
prayer,
cue-605
staying alert and continuing faithfully
for all believers.
cue-606
This kind of watchfulness means being
diligent, patient, attentive, and
cue-607
respectful.
cue-608
We must search the Word if we want to
learn how to pray.
cue-609
God is spirit, and those who worship Him
must worship in spirit and in
cue-610
truth.
cue-611
Aids to devotion.
cue-612
I do not judge how others practice their
devotion. I speak only for myself.
cue-613
Private prayer is so hard to keep up that
I do not criticize those who use helps
cue-614
that I personally find distracting. Some
people are helped by symbols or
cue-615
pictures. Many use devotional books.
cue-616
Writers like Thomas à Kempis, Lancelot
Andrews, William Law, and
cue-617
Andrew Murray, along with the hymns of
the church, have helped many people learn
cue-618
to pray.
cue-619
I value these in their place, but I do not
bring them into my inner room of prayer.
cue-620
There are two dangers to avoid:
cue-621
false emotion and too much mental
distraction.
cue-622
One sincere believer, who was very active
in serving others,
cue-623
realized he was not praying.
cue-624
He decided to spend half an hour each day
in private prayer.
cue-625
But after a month, he stopped because it
felt unreal.
cue-626
He could not keep speaking or thinking for
that long when he felt no one was there.
cue-627
Instead of sensing God's presence, he felt
an absence.
cue-628
True prayer cannot be based on pretending
or forcing emotion. The heart
cue-629
cannot keep up something unreal day after
day. The mind also cannot
cue-630
function in emptiness.
cue-631
God is present in secret, and it is His
real presence that makes that
cue-632
place holy.
cue-633
Worship must have both spirit and truth.
cue-634
Nowhere is this more important than in the
quiet place of
cue-635
prayer.The
cue-636
fire of devotion is lit and strengthened
by truth, but that truth must reach the
cue-637
heart. Studying spiritual things does not
always lead to real devotion.
cue-638
A person can become so focused on ideas
that they miss the experience itself.
cue-639
Learning about spiritual truth does not
always become a living reality. Even the
cue-640
experiences of others can mislead us if we
rely on them instead of seeking
cue-641
God for ourselves.
cue-642
Even the Bible, if used wrongly, can
become a hindrance.
cue-643
Light itself can blind.
cue-644
Our Lord rebuked religious teachers
because their misuse of scripture kept
cue-645
them from seeing the truth.
cue-646
Things meant to help us can become
obstacles. What should guide us can trip
cue-647
us.
cue-648
In matters of the soul, each person must
find the help that truly leads
cue-649
them to God.
cue-650
The devotional use of the Bible.
cue-651
Can we still take the Bible with us into
the place of prayer?
cue-652
One of the greatest losses has been that
many no longer use it as a devotional
cue-653
book.
cue-654
A person cannot truly pray from a book
they no longer trust.
cue-655
Truth is necessary both for God and for
us.
cue-656
If we are to worship, we must do so in
spirit and in truth.
cue-657
Some teachers often criticize the
traditional view of the Bible, yet still
cue-658
claim that nothing has been lost.
cue-659
They say it remains the living and
powerful word of God. They also
cue-660
admit that Jesus accepted the scriptures
as they were. He found his
cue-661
message in them, fed his soul on them,
and depended on them in every major moment
cue-662
of his life.
cue-663
A disciple should be willing to follow the
example of his Lord.
cue-664
There are ways of studying the Bible that
do not belong to the inner place of
cue-665
prayer.
cue-666
Methods such as studying history, literary
analysis, and critical
cue-667
approaches deal with outward matters and
belong in study and
cue-668
discussion. They focus on the external
setting and the gradual
cue-669
unfolding of revealed truth.
cue-670
But in the place of prayer, the scriptures
are received as the living and sovereign
cue-671
word of God.
cue-672
Though many writers were inspired, there
is only one true author.
cue-673
As it is written, "Holy men of God spoke
as they were moved by the Holy Spirit."
cue-674
Questions about dates, authorship, and
similar matters are set
cue-675
aside, not because ignorance helps prayer,
but because such
cue-676
questions are not relevant there.
cue-677
Every part of scripture has a message tied
to its time and place,
cue-678
but it also carries a truth that is
eternal and for all
cue-679
people. Historical knowledge helps bring
fuller understanding,
cue-680
yet the soul in prayer comes to scripture
to meet God.
cue-681
To the praying soul, it is the unfailing,
sovereign, and saving word of
cue-682
God.
cue-683
So we can still take the scriptures into
the quiet place of prayer.
cue-684
Even scholars often admit that their
debates are not about the most important
cue-685
matters, and in the end, their certain
conclusions are often only
cue-686
widely accepted ideas.
cue-687
I do not want to dwell too much on
biblical criticism, but it may help if I
cue-688
explain how I view the scriptures.
cue-689
To me, there is a clear comparison between
the word of the Lord and the law of the
cue-690
land.
cue-691
A judge and jury accept the law. Their
role is not to criticize or change
cue-692
it, but to understand and apply it.
cue-693
They are not concerned with the politics
or the people who created the law.
cue-694
It can be interesting to study the history
behind a law, to learn the situation it
cue-695
addressed, the efforts of reformers, who
wrote it, and how it was revised.
cue-696
But that work belongs to historians and
specialists.
cue-697
Even a lawyer may not know these details.
His task is to know the law
cue-698
itself.
cue-699
The judge's task is to interpret it, and
the jury's task is to
cue-700
submit to its authority.
cue-701
In the same way, with the word of God,
questions about how many authors there
cue-702
were, how the books were formed, or what
sources were used are not the main
cue-703
concern.
cue-704
The scriptures have moved beyond their
human and historical beginnings.
cue-705
Because they were given by inspiration,
they remain the enduring word of the Lord.
cue-706
We take the Bible into the place of
prayer not to study its
cue-707
literary history,
cue-708
but to listen for what the Lord, our God,
is saying to us.
cue-709
The praying method in the word.
cue-710
St. Paul said, "I will pray with the
understanding also."
cue-711
The word of God gives understanding to
prayer.
cue-712
The Bible is not an easy book for those
who are unfamiliar with it.
cue-713
Because of this, many turn to simple,
structured devotional books.
cue-714
Yet the Bible itself is meant to be a
guide to prayer for ordinary people if
cue-715
it is rightly understood.
cue-716
I think it may help you most if I explain
my own way of using it. The
cue-717
first question is where to begin. Each
person must find his own starting
cue-718
point.
cue-719
I began with the Psalms.
cue-720
The next question is the best time of day.
cue-721
When I first began, I had to wake at five
in the morning and be at work by six,
cue-722
so I read my passage the night before. I
read the selected portion
cue-723
slowly, with a spirit of prayer, going
over it several times.
cue-724
Then, on my knees, I took it line by line,
turning each part
cue-725
into prayer and thanksgiving.
cue-726
After that, I wrote down the verse or
phrase that especially spoke to
cue-727
me.The next morning, as I dressed, I read
it again,
cue-728
briefly committed the day to God, and
carried the verse with me.
cue-729
Before I followed this method, I used to
try to force myself into a mood of prayer,
cue-730
but I lacked direction, and prayer became
empty words with no sense of
cue-731
listening.
cue-732
Since then, prayer has become full of
wonder, rich in thought, and a
cue-733
true fellowship with God
cue-734
because it is guided, awakened, and
inspired by His Word.
cue-735
Along with this simple method,
cue-736
I have found great help in using the
marginal references, especially those in
cue-737
the Revised Version.
cue-738
The Holy Spirit teaches us to compare
Scripture with Scripture and spiritual
cue-739
truth with spiritual truth.
cue-740
The same Spirit who inspired the
Scriptures is given to help us understand
cue-741
them.
cue-742
The Holy Spirit and the Word of God never
disagree.
cue-743
Revelation unfolds step by step, and each
part has its place and
cue-744
meaning.
cue-745
Watching this unfolding deeply moves the
soul.
cue-746
New insights awaken the mind and stir
worship and praise.
cue-747
Is this prayer?
cue-748
Yes, it is, so long as it remains focused
on devotion and is not
cue-749
pursued for any other purpose.
cue-750
I once tried using passages meant for
study or examination as my devotional
cue-751
reading,
cue-752
but it left my time empty and unhelpful.
cue-753
God desires the full attention of the
spirit, just as we long to be aware of His
cue-754
real presence.
cue-755
The soul is never less alone than when it
is alone with God.
cue-756
How to use the Word in prayer.
cue-757
It is best to use only the Bible so that
Scripture explains Scripture.
cue-758
I find it helpful to take the words of the
psalmists and prophets and turn them into
cue-759
prayer.
cue-760
Avoid distractions that pull you away from
this purpose. I have also
cue-761
noticed that many well-known Bible
scholars use the Authorized Version in
cue-762
their personal devotions,
cue-763
and I recommend following their example.
cue-764
Search the Scriptures.
cue-765
When the Word comes alive,
cue-766
the heart soon burns with it.
cue-767
The Word of God is like God's world.
cue-768
All of it is interesting and wonderful,
cue-769
yet there are places we return to again
and again with special love.
cue-770
There are passages we never tire of, and
others made sacred by deep personal
cue-771
meaning.
cue-772
Some pages of the Bible become worn from
frequent use, and some are marked by
cue-773
tears.
cue-774
There is no book of prayer like the
Psalms.
cue-775
Certain Psalms seem to reflect the journey
of the soul.
cue-776
I especially love Psalms thirty-seven,
forty-six, eighty, and one
cue-777
hundred and sixteen, along with many
others.
cue-778
Usually, I read through a whole Psalm,
then return to a few verses that stand out
cue-779
to me and meditate on them.
cue-780
How often I have answered worry with trust
in Psalm thirty-seven,
cue-781
committing my way to the Lord, repeating
and praying the words, "Rest in the
cue-782
Lord and wait patiently for Him."
cue-783
My soul finds joy in the promise that if I
delight in the Lord, He will
cue-784
give me the desires of my heart.
cue-785
It is a great thing to take the Lord's own
words, speak them in praise, and
cue-786
use them as prayers before Him.
cue-787
The forty-sixth Psalm is just as
wonderful, with its three parts:
cue-788
disaster, conflict, and witness.
cue-789
Then I return to the first verse, which
describes God as our refuge,
cue-790
strength, and help.
cue-791
A refuge is a place of safety in dangers
where we are completely helpless.
cue-792
What can we do against a shaking earth,
falling mountains, or raging storms?
cue-793
When sudden trouble comes and everything
seems to give way beneath us,
cue-794
God is our refuge.
cue-795
The eternal God is thy refuge, and
underneath are the everlasting arms,
cue-796
always underneath,
cue-797
always deeper than our deepest need.
cue-798
God is also our strength.
cue-799
There are demands we cannot meet and
enemies we cannot face on our own.
cue-800
He giveth power to the faint, and to them
that have no might, He increaseth
cue-801
strength.
cue-802
At once, the mind turns to the great
people of faith,
cue-803
and we are encouraged with the promise
that strength will be given for each
cue-804
day. God is also our help.
cue-805
There are times when we are not enough on
our own. A helper comes near,
cue-806
bringing support, encouragement, guidance,
and strength to act.
cue-807
What more could we need for assurance?
cue-808
It is no wonder the heart draws close to
God and quietly says,
cue-809
"I will trust and not be afraid."
cue-810
The Lord of Hosts is with us. The God of
Jacob is our refuge.
cue-811
I have often prayed through Psalm one
hundred and sixteen.
cue-812
It was one of the first gifts God gave me.
cue-813
There is no need to change the wording
since every verse already speaks
cue-814
personally. I love how it moves between
deep sorrow and joyful
cue-815
thanksgiving,
cue-816
and I spend much time on the promises made
by a soul that has been saved.
cue-817
The writer had gone through great depths.
cue-818
Troubles came all at once, and worst of
all, he had lost his trust in both
cue-819
God and people.
cue-820
But deliverance came when he prayed.
cue-821
Prayer led to praise, and praise became a
thankful
cue-822
offering.Return to your rest, O my soul,
for the
cue-823
Lord has been good to you. For you have
delivered my soul from death, my eyes
cue-824
from tears, and my feet from falling.
cue-825
I will walk before the Lord in the land of
the living.
cue-826
There are passages of Scripture that I
read at certain times.
cue-827
One of my earliest efforts at serious
Bible study was to arrange in order the
cue-828
actions and words of our Lord during the
week of His passion.
cue-829
I still return to those passages each year
during that sacred week.
cue-830
There are also suitable readings for
Advent and other seasons of the Christian
cue-831
year.
cue-832
When I begin using a new Bible,
cue-833
I first mark the passages in the Gospel of
John where our Lord promises the Holy
cue-834
Spirit.
cue-835
I read these regularly between Easter and
Pentecost, and in doing so,
cue-836
my place of prayer becomes like the upper
room of my Lord.
cue-837
There are also three portions of Scripture
that I have read on fixed days for more
cue-838
than forty years.
cue-839
Every Sunday morning, I read Revelation
chapter five, and every Sunday night,
cue-840
Revelation chapter seven, beginning at
verse nine.
cue-841
I do this because Sunday is the central
day of my week.
cue-842
I may preach on other days, but this is
the Lord's Day, set apart for
cue-843
worship and the ministry of the Word.
cue-844
On this day, I carry the responsibility of
interceding, teaching,
cue-845
proclaiming, and calling others to faith.
cue-846
I am to represent Christ, preach Christ,
and plead for Christ.
cue-847
For such work, I need a clear vision of
Him.
cue-848
Nowhere do I see Him more fully than in
these passages, revealed at the center of
cue-849
the throne, among the redeemed, surrounded
by angels, and over all
cue-850
creation.
cue-851
After seeing His glory and saying, "Amen,
hallelujah," I am ready to face
cue-852
the day. At night, I return again to the
vision of His final victory.
cue-853
I commit the day to Him and find rest in
His presence.
cue-854
On Monday morning, I always read Isaiah
forty-one, beginning at verse
cue-855
eight.
cue-856
Monday can be a difficult day for one who
has preached on Sunday.
cue-857
The brightness of the Lord's Day can seem
to fade, and discouragement may come.
cue-858
I determined early in my ministry that if
I had to face such feelings, I would
cue-859
not give in to them.
cue-860
God gave me this passage as a safeguard
against them.
cue-861
This began in my first month after leaving
college.
cue-862
One Monday morning, I was in my room,
wrapped in a blanket, cold and unwell.
cue-863
It rained heavily all morning.
cue-864
Near noon, a visitor arrived,
cue-865
H.S.B. Yates, a minister I had only met a
few times.
cue-866
When I asked how he was, he said,
cue-867
"I am a worm and no man."
cue-868
He was deeply discouraged.
cue-869
Though his church had been full the night
before, he had been troubled afterward
cue-870
with doubt and fear.
cue-871
He asked me what I did when I felt low and
worthless.
cue-872
I had just been reading Isaiah forty-one,
so I said,
cue-873
"This chapter is for you. It is God's
promise to a worm."
cue-874
We read it together and prayed through it.
cue-875
He left greatly comforted.
cue-876
Since then, I have read that passage every
Monday morning. I have found it a strong
cue-877
defense against discouragement.
cue-878
Because of it, Monday has often become one
of my most active and joyful days.
cue-879
In this way, I continue through the Bible,
using its passages to guide my
cue-880
prayer and strengthen my soul.
cue-881
These are personal words, but now you can
understand why the Word of the Lord is so
cue-882
precious to me.
cue-883
All along, I have kept in mind those who
are busy and burdened with work,
cue-884
who have little time or space for quiet
prayer.
cue-885
That is why I urge the use of the Bible as
the only necessary book for
cue-886
devotion.
cue-887
For the same reason, I recommend reading
short portions so that prayer
cue-888
remains the main focus in the times set
apart for God.
cue-889
Chapter six: Praying in the Name.
cue-890
The most amazing promises are given about
prayer.
cue-891
The Old Testament is full of both promises
and examples.
cue-892
God promised help, guidance, grace, and
rescue to those who
cue-893
called on Him and trusted their lives to
Him.
cue-894
Nothing was too hard for the Lord, and
nothing was impossible for those who
cue-895
prayed.
cue-896
Some verses strongly challenge us to pray.
For example,
cue-897
"Thus says the Lord, the Holy One of
Israel, and its Maker:
cue-898
Ask me about the things to come concerning
my children, and command me concerning
cue-899
the work of my hands."
cue-900
Here, prayer moves from simply asking to
speaking with bold authority.
cue-901
There is no limit to what prayer can do.
cue-902
The Old Testament proves this through many
examples that show its power.
cue-903
Jesus speaks in the same unlimited way. He
says,
cue-904
"Ask and it will be given to you. Seek and
you will find.
cue-905
Knock and it will be opened to you.
cue-906
For everyone who asks receives. The one
who seeks finds,
cue-907
and to the one who knocks it will be
opened."
cue-908
He gave prayer a new foundation, greater
confidence, and a wider reach.
cue-909
He based it on the truth that God is our
Father in heaven.
cue-910
Prayer is like a child asking a loving
parent.
cue-911
If you, though you are sinful, know how to
give good gifts to your children,
cue-912
how much more will your Father in heaven
give good things to those who ask
cue-913
Him?There is another saying of Jesus that
is even more surprising.
cue-914
Therefore I tell you, whatever you ask for
in prayer, believe that you have received
cue-915
it, and it will be yours.
cue-916
Whatsoever you shall ask in my name.
cue-917
The promises about prayer reach their
highest point in the upper room on that
cue-918
unforgettable night,
cue-919
filled with both deep truth and coming
sorrow.
cue-920
Jesus said that he himself would be the
foundation of prayer.
cue-921
From then on, they were to pray in a new
way, in his name, and their
cue-922
prayers would be answered because of him.
cue-923
Just as there are seven sayings from the
cross, there are also seven teachings
cue-924
about prayer given in the upper room.
cue-925
These gather together everything taught in
scripture about prayer,
cue-926
expanding and confirming God's promises.
cue-927
It feels almost wrong to change them, for
no other words are like them. And whatever
cue-928
you ask in my name,
cue-929
I will do it so that the Father may be
glorified in the Son. If you ask
cue-930
anything in my name,
cue-931
I will do it.
cue-932
If you remain in me and my words remain in
you,
cue-933
you may ask whatever you wish, and it will
be done for you.
cue-934
You did not choose me, but I chose you and
appointed you to go and bear fruit,
cue-935
fruit that will last.
cue-936
Then the Father will give you whatever you
ask in my name.
cue-937
Now you are filled with sorrow, but I will
see you again, and your hearts will
cue-938
rejoice, and no one will take away your
joy. In that day, you will
cue-939
no longer ask me anything. Truly, truly, I
say to you,
cue-940
whatever you ask the Father in my name, he
will give you. Until now you
cue-941
have not asked anything in my name. Ask
and you will receive,
cue-942
so that your joy may be complete. In that
day you will ask
cue-943
in my name.
cue-944
These are remarkable promises given to
those who pray in the name of our Lord and
cue-945
Savior Jesus Christ.
cue-946
They are broad and far-reaching. Anything,
whatever you ask.
cue-947
Prayer reaches its highest place when it
is offered in his name,
cue-948
because it brings the one who prays into
close unity with him.
cue-949
In the name of our Lord Jesus Christ.
cue-950
Our Lord did not explain what it means to
pray in his name. The meaning was
cue-951
already clear to every Israelite. God was
present in his name.
cue-952
He had chosen his people so they would
understand, guard, and represent his
cue-953
name.
cue-954
But when they dishonored his name in their
own land and brought shame to it among
cue-955
the nations,
cue-956
he acted to restore them
cue-957
for the honor of his name.
cue-958
I do not do this for your sake, but for my
holy name's sake, which you have
cue-959
dishonored among the nations where you
have gone.
cue-960
And I will make my great name holy again.
cue-961
Our Lord speaks as God himself.
cue-962
To pray in Christ's name means much more
than simply adding the words for Christ's
cue-963
sake to our prayers.
cue-964
A name represents a person's character,
nature, and identity. The
cue-965
person is present in the name. So to pray
in Christ's name is to
cue-966
pray in a way that agrees with his
character and his will.
cue-967
It is to pray as someone who is united
with him,
cue-968
whose thoughts reflect his mind, whose
desires match his desires,
cue-969
and whose purpose is the same as his.
cue-970
When a person is united with Christ in
this way, it helps us understand and
cue-971
properly apply the promises about prayer.
cue-972
The promises that seem absolute and
unlimited are shaped and guided by him.
cue-973
In the Old Testament, prayer depended on
urgency, deep feeling, and
cue-974
sincerity.
cue-975
God answered those who cried out to him in
great need, who sought him with all their
cue-976
heart, and who were honest in their
motives.
cue-977
People learned that God desires truth in
the inner being. They were not heard if
cue-978
they held on to sin in their hearts or
spoke to him with false words.
cue-979
Our Lord also taught that prayer requires
persistence and a forgiving spirit.
cue-980
But when we pray in his name,
cue-981
all these conditions come together and are
made simple in him.
cue-982
Sincerity is tested by his name. Motives
are judged by his name.
cue-983
Prayer is examined by his name. Prayer is
made holy by his name.
cue-984
Prayer is accepted through his name when
it agrees with his character, his mind,
cue-985
his desires, and his purpose.
cue-986
This is why in John fifteen seven, his
words are closely tied to his
cue-987
name.
cue-988
If you remain in me and my words remain in
you,
cue-989
you may ask whatever you wish, and it will
be done for you.
cue-990
This is similar to what the psalmist says,
cue-991
Delight yourself in the Lord, and he will
give you the desires of your heart.
cue-992
And also what John writes,
cue-993
Beloved, if our hearts do not condemn us,
we have confidence before
cue-994
God. And whatever we ask, we receive from
him, because we keep his
cue-995
commandments and do what pleases him.
Prayers offered in
cue-996
Christ's name are examined and made holy
by his nature, his purpose, and
cue-997
his will.
cue-998
When they agree with him, he approves
them.
cue-999
For the sake of the name.
cue-1000
It means even more than this. We are heard
because of him.
cue-1001
He himself is the one who presents our
prayers. He lives forever to
cue-1002
pray for us.In Revelation, he is shown as
taking our
cue-1003
prayers and adding to them the fire from
the altar,
cue-1004
making them powerful and acceptable.
cue-1005
He told his disciples that he was going to
the Father and would pray for them,
cue-1006
and whatever they ask the Father in his
name, the Father would do.
cue-1007
They would be heard not because of
themselves, but because of him.
cue-1008
When I was in Leeds, a man traveled a long
distance to visit a factory he was
cue-1009
interested in.
cue-1010
He wrote to the company, but his request
was politely refused.
cue-1011
He then went in person and gave them his
card, but it was returned, and he
cue-1012
was not allowed in.
cue-1013
No matter what he said, he could not get
past the small window in the front office.
cue-1014
He shared his disappointment with a
friend, who suggested that I might help
cue-1015
him.
cue-1016
So he came to see me.
cue-1017
I gave him my card and wrote a note to the
head of the company.
cue-1018
The next day, he went again, made his
request, and handed them my card.
cue-1019
This time, every door was opened to him at
once.
cue-1020
His request was granted, but not because
of who he was.
cue-1021
The owner saw me in him.
cue-1022
In this same way, we pray in Christ's
name.
cue-1023
He approves our requests and makes them
his own, and the Father listens
cue-1024
to him.
cue-1025
We are not heard because we speak loudly
or use beautiful words or shed
cue-1026
many tears.
cue-1027
We are not heard because of our good deeds
or sacrifices.
cue-1028
Prayer in his name is answered because of
who he is.
cue-1029
In the quiet place of prayer, we ask,
cue-1030
seek, and knock in his holy name.
cue-1031
We offer our prayers with full confidence
in his promise.
cue-1032
You did not choose me, but I chose you and
appointed you,
cue-1033
so that whatever you ask the Father in my
name, he may give it to you.
cue-1034
Ask, and you will receive.
cue-1035
Chapter Seven:
cue-1036
Praying in the Spirit.
cue-1037
Early in 1882, I had an experience that
lifted my life to a new level of
cue-1038
understanding and power. I received the
gift of the Holy Spirit.
cue-1039
I was led in ways I did not understand,
for I had hardly even heard that such an
cue-1040
experience was possible.
cue-1041
The pressure of a task that felt
impossible made me aware of my need.
cue-1042
I had no strength or ability, either in my
work or in my prayers.
cue-1043
So I began to pray for power,
cue-1044
for my work,
cue-1045
and God led me to the answer by first
teaching me how to pray.
cue-1046
This surprised me because I thought I
already knew how to pray.
cue-1047
I had prayed much about the work God had
given me.
cue-1048
But when I truly began to seek power,
cue-1049
I started to hear things I had not noticed
before,
cue-1050
even before I began to understand them
clearly.
cue-1051
I listened to testimonies I had once
ignored.
cue-1052
Others had also come to God because they
lacked power, but they always connected
cue-1053
power with a deeper experience of
holiness, something I had not really
cue-1054
desired.
cue-1055
What I wanted was power.
cue-1056
I wanted power to succeed.
cue-1057
My main concern was the success that power
would bring.
cue-1058
I wanted success that would fill my
church, save people, and break down the
cue-1059
strongholds of Satan.
cue-1060
I was young, and I was impatient.
cue-1061
Twelve of us began to pray together, and
the answer came
cue-1062
in a way we never expected, like when his
people
cue-1063
passed through the sea, protected by walls
like crystal.
cue-1064
He led us to Pentecost. That experience
became the key to my whole life.
cue-1065
It awakened my understanding and cleansed
my heart.
cue-1066
It gave me new joy and new power, a new
love, and a deeper compassion.
cue-1067
It opened the Bible to me in a new way and
gave me a new message to share.
cue-1068
Above all, it gave me a new understanding
and a closer fellowship with
cue-1069
God in prayer.
cue-1070
It taught me how to pray in the Spirit.
cue-1071
The cooperation of the Spirit.
cue-1072
The Holy Spirit always works together with
us.
cue-1073
He does not act alone. He chooses to work
through people to express his thoughts,
cue-1074
reveal truth, and carry out God's will.
cue-1075
He lives in the body of Christ, just as
Christ lived in the body prepared for him
cue-1076
by the Holy Spirit.
cue-1077
God's message came through the Spirit of
truth, but it was written down by human
cue-1078
hands.
cue-1079
This partnership between God and people is
seen throughout the whole work of
cue-1080
salvation in Christ.
cue-1081
Jesus was born of a woman, but he was
conceived by the Holy Spirit. He
cue-1082
grew and learned in Joseph's home, guided
by the Spirit.
cue-1083
His teaching and ministry were done in the
power of the Spirit. He offered himself
cue-1084
to God through the eternal Spirit, and it
was the Spirit who raised him from the
cue-1085
dead.
cue-1086
This same pattern continues in our
salvation.
cue-1087
There is always both a human part and a
divine part.
cue-1088
There is a shared witness, a shared
guidance, a shared work, and even a
cue-1089
shared intercession.
cue-1090
We pray in the Spirit, and the Spirit also
prays for us.
cue-1091
The fellowship of the Spirit in prayer.
cue-1092
The Holy Spirit does not act on his own or
for his own purposes.
cue-1093
His work is to glorify Christ, and
everything he does is based on what
cue-1094
Christ has already finished.
cue-1095
He could not be given until Jesus was
glorified.
cue-1096
In the same way, there can be no true
Pentecost in our experience until
cue-1097
Christ is honored as Lord.The Spirit is
the gift given
cue-1098
after Christ's coronation, whom the Father
has made both Lord and Christ.
cue-1099
Our partnership with the Spirit in prayer
comes through our life in Christ.
cue-1100
This is explained in Romans eight, verses
nine to twenty-seven.
cue-1101
Those who pray in the Spirit must live in
the Spirit.
cue-1102
If the Spirit is to pray for us, He must
live within us. If we live by our
cue-1103
sinful nature, we will die.
cue-1104
But if we are led by the Spirit and live
according to Him,
cue-1105
then He lives in us, works through us, and
guides us.
cue-1106
Then this becomes true.
cue-1107
The Spirit helps us in our weakness.
cue-1108
We do not know how we should pray, but the
Spirit himself prays for us with deep
cue-1109
feelings that cannot be put into words.
cue-1110
And God, who searches our hearts, knows
the mind of the Spirit because the Spirit
cue-1111
prays for God's people according to his
will.
cue-1112
The Holy Spirit understands the deep
things of God. He takes what belongs to
cue-1113
Christ and makes it known to us.
cue-1114
God knows the mind of the Spirit,
cue-1115
so we pray in the Spirit, taught and
guided by Him, and He also prays for
cue-1116
us in ways beyond words.
cue-1117
This is how prayer truly works in the New
Testament.
cue-1118
Even though I did not understand it at the
time, this is what happened to me when
cue-1119
God gave me new understanding, new joy,
and new power in prayer.
cue-1120
A new person came to live within me and
made my heart his place of worship.
cue-1121
So now I live, but not by my own strength.
cue-1122
In the same way, I pray, but not by
myself.
cue-1123
I pray in the Spirit, and the Spirit
himself prays within me.
cue-1124
The Spirit helping our weakness.
cue-1125
The Holy Spirit teaches and guides all
true prayer.
cue-1126
It is very true that we do not know what
we should pray for as we ought.
cue-1127
There is no area where we reach the limits
of our understanding more quickly than in
cue-1128
prayer. We usually pray for things that
feel urgent and obvious,
cue-1129
but we cannot see deeply enough or far
enough to know what we truly need.
cue-1130
Most people want good health, a
comfortable home, pleasant circumstances,
cue-1131
happy friendships, more money, and
greater success.
cue-1132
But who can be sure these things are truly
best for them?
cue-1133
God sees much more than we do, and his
will may be different.
cue-1134
Many people have prayed with deep sorrow
for someone to live
cue-1135
and later came to thank God that he took
them when he did.
cue-1136
God knew what was ahead and spared them
from what was to come.
cue-1137
The Holy Spirit knows the mind of Christ
and the will of God.
cue-1138
He teaches us both how to pray and what to
pray for.
cue-1139
If anyone lacks wisdom, they should ask
God not only for answers,
cue-1140
but for the spirit of wisdom who teaches,
strengthens, and guides.
cue-1141
The Holy Spirit also shapes the right
conditions for prayer. We can ask
cue-1142
wrongly, not only in what we ask, but in
why we ask it. He
cue-1143
makes our desires pure and brings them
into agreement with God's will
cue-1144
so that we begin to desire what God
desires to give.
cue-1145
That is why when we delight ourselves in
the Lord, He gives us the desires of our
cue-1146
hearts because our desires have become
like His.
cue-1147
The Spirit also expresses the deep needs
of our souls, even when we can't put them
cue-1148
into words.
cue-1149
His deep stirrings come before our
prayers, and our prayers grow out of what
cue-1150
He is already doing within us.
cue-1151
In Him, we find everything we need for
prayer:
cue-1152
life, desire, wisdom, faith, intercession,
and power.
cue-1153
He awakens desire, purifies our motives,
gives us confidence, and
cue-1154
strengthens our faith.
cue-1155
The prayer of the Spirit.
cue-1156
This is the true meaning of prayer.
cue-1157
It is more than asking for things. It is
sharing life with God. It is
cue-1158
fellowship, partnership, and unity with
the Father and the Son through the Holy
cue-1159
Spirit.
cue-1160
Prayer is more than words. In fact, it is
often strongest when no words
cue-1161
are spoken.
cue-1162
It is more than making requests, for it
reaches its highest point when it simply
cue-1163
worships and asks for nothing.
cue-1164
A child once walked into his father's
study and came up to him at his desk.
cue-1165
The father turned and said,
cue-1166
"What do you want, son?"
cue-1167
The child replied,
cue-1168
"Nothing, Dad. I just wanted to be with
you."
cue-1169
This mystery of the Spirit is the key to
many other mysteries.
cue-1170
The Lord shares his secrets with those who
pray in close fellowship with the Spirit.
cue-1171
There are different levels of prayer. At
one level, we
cue-1172
pray and ask God to help us.
cue-1173
But there is a higher way
cue-1174
where the Spirit prays and we agree with
Him. His prayer becomes
cue-1175
our prayer.
cue-1176
He prays within our hearts while our Lord
continually prays for us at the
cue-1177
Father's right hand.
cue-1178
The Spirit within us works in us, shaping
our desires and actions so
cue-1179
that we follow the will and purpose of our
Father in heaven.
cue-1180
He is God the Spirit, representing both
the Father and the Son,
cue-1181
and the three are one God.
cue-1182
He is the power working within us.
cue-1183
He brings hearts together in prayer and
makes them united and strong in
cue-1184
intercession.
cue-1185
The confidence that our prayers are
answered comes from Him.
cue-1186
He makes prayer the most powerful force in
God's kingdom.The secret of
cue-1187
it all is in Him.
cue-1188
The power of it all comes through Him. The
joy of it all is found with Him. The
cue-1189
greatest thing God ever did for me was to
teach me how to pray in the Spirit.
cue-1190
We are not truly people of prayer in the
fullest sense until we are filled with the
cue-1191
Holy Spirit.
cue-1192
So we pray,
cue-1193
Lord, teach us to pray in the Spirit.
cue-1194
Chapter Eight:
cue-1195
Praying to God Our Father.
cue-1196
Jesus based prayer on a personal
relationship.
cue-1197
He taught us to call God our Father, and
this truth of being His children changes
cue-1198
everything about prayer.
cue-1199
Even if some difficulties remain, there
must be communication between a father and
cue-1200
his child.
cue-1201
To say that a child cannot ask anything
from a father would take away the meaning
cue-1202
of both words.
cue-1203
A child has the right to ask, and a father
has the responsibility to
cue-1204
listen with love and understanding.
cue-1205
The true wonder is not that God answers
prayer, but that He is our Father.
cue-1206
Once we understand that, prayer becomes
natural and reasonable. If
cue-1207
God is truly our Father, then prayer must
be possible.
cue-1208
God would not be a father if His children
could not come to Him in
cue-1209
prayer. All that Jesus taught about having
a childlike heart in God's
cue-1210
kingdom would make no sense if God were
not truly our Father.
cue-1211
This relationship means we can come to Him
freely, closely, and
cue-1212
without fear. Some children of great men
have thought of their fathers
cue-1213
as distant figures instead of loving
parents.
cue-1214
In the same way, some people think of God
as only an authority or an
cue-1215
institution.
cue-1216
But this is not how Jesus revealed Him.
cue-1217
Our Father in Heaven.
cue-1218
Calling God our Father does not lessen His
greatness. He is still the Holy and Most
cue-1219
High God, the one who lives forever.
cue-1220
When Jesus spoke of God caring for
sparrows and lilies in the Sermon on the
cue-1221
Mount, He did not take away anything from
the greatness seen in Isaiah's vision.
cue-1222
The everlasting God, the Lord, the creator
of the ends of the earth.
cue-1223
He is still the King eternal, immortal,
invisible, the only
cue-1224
wise God, the blessed and only ruler, the
King of Kings and Lord
cue-1225
of Lords, who alone is immortal and lives
in unapproachable light, whom
cue-1226
no one has seen or can see.
cue-1227
There are many descriptions of God's glory
and greatness, and it is good to think
cue-1228
about them with worship and awe. But Jesus
Christ brought all of this
cue-1229
into a personal relationship.
cue-1230
He is our Father.
cue-1231
That is the greatest truth of all. To a
child, he is simply
cue-1232
father. Others may feel afraid, but a
child does not.
cue-1233
I remember when I was young being invited
to visit the parsonage.
cue-1234
I was so nervous that I walked past the
door several times before I found the
cue-1235
courage to knock.
cue-1236
My heart was pounding as I stood there.
cue-1237
But when I was let inside, I was surprised
to see the respected minister on the
cue-1238
floor playing with his children.
cue-1239
They were laughing, climbing on him, and
even using his long beard like
cue-1240
reins as if he were a horse.
cue-1241
He was their father.
cue-1242
They did not feel the fear that others
felt toward him.
cue-1243
As they grew older and began to understand
his importance, their respect increased,
cue-1244
but their confidence and freedom with him
did not change.
cue-1245
Children in their father's house are free
and unafraid.
cue-1246
Pray to the Father who is in secret.
cue-1247
Heaven itself cannot contain God our
Father,
cue-1248
yet He is present in the inner place of
the soul.
cue-1249
He is there in secret, and He sees in
secret.
cue-1250
He waits for us to open the door of our
hearts to Him.
cue-1251
This is holy ground and should be
approached with reverence. The soul must
cue-1252
gather all its strength for this highest
act of prayer.
cue-1253
Here, the mind must be clear and focused,
thinking deeply about God
cue-1254
and about life.
cue-1255
Thinking about God is more than just
thinking our own ideas about Him.
cue-1256
True fellowship with Him goes deeper than
any study or teaching.
cue-1257
Private prayer is life itself, speaking in
the awareness that God our Father is
cue-1258
present.
cue-1259
Before Him, everything is opened
willingly, all pretending is removed from
cue-1260
our motives,
cue-1261
all false desire is stripped away, and all
dishonesty is taken from our
cue-1262
words.
cue-1263
Quietness is the best preparation before
speaking to God.
cue-1264
When we understand His greatness as our
Father, it gives new meaning to His
cue-1265
glory,
cue-1266
and prayer opens up new depths when we see
the majesty of our Father in Heaven.
cue-1267
If God is our Father, then we can pray.
But if He is such a loving
cue-1268
father, why do we need to pray at all?
cue-1269
Jesus said,
cue-1270
"When you pray, do not keep repeating
empty words like those who do not
cue-1271
know God. They think they will be heard
because of their many words.
cue-1272
Do not be like them, for your Father knows
what you need before you ask Him."
cue-1273
So why ask?
cue-1274
We do not pray to give God information. He
already knows. We do not
cue-1275
pray to persuade Him. His love does not
need to be convinced. No good father
cue-1276
would give his child a stone when he asks
for bread
cue-1277
or something harmful when he asks for
food.
cue-1278
A father's wisdom and love work together
to meet real needs, not to mock
cue-1279
them.Even human fathers, though imperfect,
know how to
cue-1280
care for their children.
cue-1281
If you, though you are sinful, know how to
give good gifts to your children,
cue-1282
how much more will your Father in heaven
give good things to those who ask him?
cue-1283
Ask and it will be given to you;
cue-1284
seek and you will find; knock and the door
will be opened to you.
cue-1285
For everyone who asks receives; the one
who seeks finds,
cue-1286
and to the one who knocks, the door will
be opened
cue-1287
if you call on him as Father.
cue-1288
We are not trying here to solve every
question about prayer.
cue-1289
We want to learn how to pray, and empty
arguments do not help us do that.
cue-1290
When a person goes into prayer, no part of
that person should be left behind.
cue-1291
Reason is a gift from God just as much as
emotion is, and if either one is
cue-1292
separated from the other, the soul becomes
weak and incomplete.
cue-1293
Love may sometimes see what reason cannot,
but reason helps guard that
cue-1294
vision and apply it to life.
cue-1295
Our spiritual life is built on knowing
God, but this is not a knowledge that
cue-1296
human effort alone can gain.
cue-1297
Love is what binds us to God in prayer.
cue-1298
If we try to explain love only by reason,
we can cool its warmth.
cue-1299
But if reason is pushed aside, emotion can
become uncontrolled.
cue-1300
Study and preaching both have their place,
cue-1301
but the inner place of prayer should be
set apart. There, prayer
cue-1302
gives light to our thinking, and our
thinking feeds the fire of the heart.
cue-1303
Seeing God as Father is the key to
understanding prayer.
cue-1304
God is more than Creator.
cue-1305
He is our Father, our heavenly Father,
holy Father, righteous
cue-1306
Father. He is the God of love, and he is
also the God of
cue-1307
law.
cue-1308
The Sabbath was made for man, and God's
universe was made for the family of God
cue-1309
in the glory of his Father.
cue-1310
The fact that we pray to God as our Father
in heaven teaches us much about how we
cue-1311
should pray.
cue-1312
The Son of God delighted in his Father's
glory.
cue-1313
He often rose early to look upon his glory
and enjoy his presence.
cue-1314
He rejoiced in the Father's greatness and
in the majesty of his power.
cue-1315
It is good to think carefully about what
Jesus said of the Father,
cue-1316
"My Father."
cue-1317
Every time he spoke those words, they were
full of love and honor.
cue-1318
God is spirit, and those who worship him
must worship in spirit and truth,
cue-1319
for the Father is seeking such people to
worship him.
cue-1320
"My Father
cue-1321
is greater than all.
cue-1322
I and the Father are one."
cue-1323
Jesus loved to speak about the Father's
care and generous love.
cue-1324
Nothing is too small for him. Each person
matters to him as though there were no
cue-1325
one else.
cue-1326
Even a single sparrow is not forgotten,
and human beings are so precious to
cue-1327
him that even the hairs on their heads are
numbered.
cue-1328
Jesus lived in complete surrender to the
will of his holy and righteous Father.
cue-1329
He did not pray in order to bend the
Father's will to his own desires.
cue-1330
He prayed that the Father's will would be
done.
cue-1331
Even in deep suffering and agonizing
prayer, he remained obedient to the
cue-1332
Father's will.
cue-1333
Because we pray to our heavenly Father in
the secret place,
cue-1334
we can come with the simple openness of
little children.
cue-1335
There is nothing too small or too great to
bring to him.
cue-1336
We come as his children, and we trust him
as our Father in heaven.
cue-1337
His answer will often be greater than what
we ask.
cue-1338
Prayer itself teaches and trains us.
cue-1339
The Holy Spirit instructs us in the school
of prayer. A true father blesses not
cue-1340
only with readiness but also with wisdom.
cue-1341
Sometimes God waits for the right time.
Sometimes the answer is given long
cue-1342
before the person who prayed knows it.
cue-1343
But still,
cue-1344
everyone who asks receives.
cue-1345
As Adoniram Judson lay dying, he heard of
a striking answer to a prayer he
cue-1346
had offered for the Jews while serving as
a missionary in Burma.
cue-1347
He said,
cue-1348
"I never prayed sincerely and earnestly
for anything unless it came.
cue-1349
At some time, no matter how far away,
somehow, in some form,
cue-1350
often the very last way I would have
expected, it came."
cue-1351
When you pray, go into your inner room,
close the door, and pray to your
cue-1352
Father who is in secret,
cue-1353
to him who is able to do immeasurably more
than all we ask or think.
cue-1354
Chapter nine: The importunity of prayer.
cue-1355
Jesus taught people to pray to God as
Father.
cue-1356
This is the heart of his teaching. When
you pray, say, "Our Father, who is in
cue-1357
heaven."
cue-1358
He warned against showing off in prayer.
cue-1359
Prayer must be in a private place with the
door shut. In that secret
cue-1360
place, prayer should be simple and
sincere.
cue-1361
False religion cannot survive where empty
repetition and impressive language
cue-1362
are not allowed.
cue-1363
Fathers and children do not make speeches
to one another.
cue-1364
God is not far away.
cue-1365
He is near. He does not need to be
informed because Jesus says,
cue-1366
"Your Father knows what you need before
you ask him."
cue-1367
He does not need to be persuaded either,
for if you, though you are sinful,
cue-1368
know how to give good gifts to your
children,
cue-1369
how much more will your Father in heaven
give good things to those who ask
cue-1370
him?Nothing could be simpler or more
comforting.
cue-1371
Ask and you will receive, for everyone who
asks
cue-1372
receives.
cue-1373
Importunity and persistence.
cue-1374
Alongside this teaching, Jesus also gave
the parables of the friend at midnight
cue-1375
and the unjust judge.
cue-1376
These parables are different from many
others because they teach by contrast, not
cue-1377
by likeness.
cue-1378
God is not like the unwilling friend or
the unjust judge.
cue-1379
So why did Jesus tell these stories? The
shared point is this.
cue-1380
In both cases, persistence won the answer.
cue-1381
If people are not heard because of many
words, they may still be heard because
cue-1382
they keep asking.
cue-1383
So what place does this kind of
persistence have in the prayers of
cue-1384
children speaking to their heavenly
Father? Jesus himself prayed with
cue-1385
deep feeling and persistence.
cue-1386
He rose early to pray. He spent whole
nights in prayer.
cue-1387
Hebrews five verse seven says that he
offered prayers and requests with loud
cue-1388
cries and tears.
cue-1389
The scene in Gethsemane is full of
mystery.
cue-1390
He prayed to God as Father, yet his prayer
was filled with deep suffering.
cue-1391
He knelt down and prayed, saying,
cue-1392
"Father, if you are willing, take this cup
from me,
cue-1393
yet not my will but yours be done."
cue-1394
And being in deep agony, he prayed more
earnestly, and his sweat was like drops
cue-1395
of blood falling to the ground.
cue-1396
Matthew twenty-six, verses thirty-eight to
forty-six tells us that he prayed the
cue-1397
same words three times.
cue-1398
Jesus did many mighty works. He calmed
storms, cast out demons,
cue-1399
and raised the dead.
cue-1400
In none of these do we see strain or
struggle.
cue-1401
Power went out from him, and his work made
him tired. Yet there was always a sense
cue-1402
of authority and ease in what he did.
cue-1403
But of his praying it is said,
cue-1404
"As he prayed, he sweat."
cue-1405
He prayed in agony, even to the point of
blood.
cue-1406
If God is Father,
cue-1407
why was there such agony in the prayers of
his Son?
cue-1408
Prayer and supplication.
cue-1409
There is a group of words that broadens
our understanding of prayer and shows that
cue-1410
it is not always as easy and simple as it
may first seem.
cue-1411
The man who came at midnight was ready to
beg, plead, and keep asking
cue-1412
until his request was granted.
cue-1413
That does not sound much like a child
speaking to a heavenly Father. God is not
cue-1414
like that unwilling friend, but prayer
that wins an answer can look like that
cue-1415
kind of persistence.
cue-1416
The same is true in the parable of the
unjust judge.
cue-1417
God is not like that judge, but prayer can
still involve pleading and
cue-1418
continuing until the answer comes.
cue-1419
A petition simply asks.
cue-1420
Supplication begs earnestly. Pleading
presents reasons.
cue-1421
Job wanted a chance to present his case
before God.
cue-1422
"Oh, that I knew where I might find him,
cue-1423
that I might come even to his seat.
cue-1424
I would lay my case before him and fill my
mouth with arguments. I would know the
cue-1425
words he would answer me and understand
what he would say to me."
cue-1426
God invites us to reason with him, and
prayer is given the freedom to
cue-1427
plead. But if God is our Father, if he
already knows our
cue-1428
needs and is ready to hear us,
cue-1429
why should prayer include begging and
pleading?
cue-1430
Striving and wrestling.
cue-1431
When Peter was in prison,
cue-1432
earnest prayer for him was made to God by
the church.
cue-1433
They kept praying through the night and
continued until the answer came.
cue-1434
We see the same kind of persistence in the
prayer of the Syrophoenician woman.
cue-1435
She held on and would not give up until
Jesus praised her faith and
cue-1436
granted her request.
cue-1437
The New Testament often connects prayer
with striving.
cue-1438
Paul urges the Christians in Rome,
cue-1439
"By our Lord Jesus Christ and by the love
of the Spirit, strive together with
cue-1440
me in your prayers to God for me." Romans
fifteen thirty.
cue-1441
He praises Epaphras as a faithful pastor
who labored earnestly in prayer,
cue-1442
Colossians four twelve.
cue-1443
And Paul says that he himself struggled
greatly for the Colossians.
cue-1444
Prayer is work. It involves effort,
struggle, and labor. But
cue-1445
why should prayer require such effort?
cue-1446
The idea of wrestling is also connected
with prayer.
cue-1447
This does not mean that we wrestle against
God, but that prayer requires firm focus,
cue-1448
determination, and watchfulness.
cue-1449
It is clear that prayer is not always the
easy matter it may seem to be when we
cue-1450
think only of simply asking our heavenly
Father for what we want.
cue-1451
There is deep struggle in it. There is
labor in it. There is pleading in it.
cue-1452
There is persistence in it.
cue-1453
Perhaps Coleridge was not far from the
truth when he said that prayer is the
cue-1454
highest work of which the human heart is
capable and the greatest effort in the
cue-1455
Christian's battle on Earth.
cue-1456
The paradox of prayer.
cue-1457
Prayer is full of things that seem
opposite to each other. It is so simple
cue-1458
that a child can pray and yet so deep that
the wisest people cannot fully
cue-1459
explain it.
cue-1460
It is so easy that even the weak can pray
and yet so demanding that it calls
cue-1461
for all our energy, understanding, and
strength.
cue-1462
Prayer is so natural that it seems to need
no teaching, and yet it rises so
cue-1463
far above human nature that it cannot be
learned by human wisdom
cue-1464
alone.Prayer is a world of its own, and no
single
cue-1465
comparison from life can fully explain it.
cue-1466
The relationship between father and child
means more in scripture than we often
cue-1467
think today.
cue-1468
Jesus spoke of God as our heavenly Father,
our holy Father, and our
cue-1469
righteous Father.
cue-1470
Peter speaks of him as both Father and
judge.
cue-1471
The modern mind does not like the idea of
prayer that includes agony, pleading,
cue-1472
striving, wrestling, and persistence.
cue-1473
People think that this is not how loving
parents would want their children to come
cue-1474
to them, and so they assume it must not be
the right way to pray.
cue-1475
For many years, I kept with me a symbolic
check drawn on the bank of
cue-1476
heaven. Dr. A.T. Pearson sent it to me
from America one Christmas.
cue-1477
It was made out to the bearer and promised
to provide whatever I might need.
cue-1478
On it were the words, "My God will supply
all your need according to his
cue-1479
riches in glory by Christ Jesus."
cue-1480
Is prayer really just like cashing a
check?
cue-1481
Is it really that simple? Is God simply
standing at the counter ready to hand
cue-1482
over whatever we ask?
cue-1483
Experience quickly corrects anyone who
thinks that is all prayer is.
cue-1484
If prayer were only that,
cue-1485
why would Jesus speak of a secret place
and a closed door?
cue-1486
The cost of prayer.
cue-1487
If God is our Father, then we are his
children, and children should grow to be
cue-1488
like their father in character, nature,
and mind.
cue-1489
The holy Father is the father of holy
children. He is in the secret place, and
cue-1490
we meet him there in secret.
cue-1491
To be alone with God is to stand before
his judgment.
cue-1492
The psalmist said,
cue-1493
"If I had cherished sin in my heart, the
Lord would not have listened."
cue-1494
We cannot truly pray while our own hearts
condemn us.
cue-1495
God does not hand out commands the way a
store hands out goods.
cue-1496
He speaks with his children and invites
them to reason with him.
cue-1497
He is ready to bless, but he also blesses
with wisdom and care.
cue-1498
Prayer is both a discipline and a
training.
cue-1499
Jesus spoke wisely when he said not to
throw pearls before swine.
cue-1500
God works in an orderly and holy way.
Intensity belongs to prayer.
cue-1501
God is found by those who seek him with
all their heart.
cue-1502
Wrestling prayer prevails. The earnest
prayer of a righteous person has great
cue-1503
power.
cue-1504
God hates false fire. We must never try to
force feelings or
cue-1505
create an artificial intensity. Avoid
anything mechanical or lifeless.
cue-1506
Stay away from casual and careless
prayer.
cue-1507
Be cautious of easy and cheap ideas of
prayer,
cue-1508
as though it were only like drawing money
from a bank or picking goods from a store.
cue-1509
Methods and forms may have their place in
public or church
cue-1510
prayer.
cue-1511
But when you are alone with God, be truly
alone with him.
cue-1512
Begin with silence.
cue-1513
Speak simply. Listen humbly. Do not leave
until you have had a real sense
cue-1514
of fellowship with him.
cue-1515
We do not need to persuade God, but he
must train and prepare us.
cue-1516
In every condition and at every time, pour
out your heart to him in
cue-1517
prayer and pleading with thanksgiving.
cue-1518
And if the Spirit leads you into deep
inward groaning, do not be afraid of the
cue-1519
pain that can come with prayer.
cue-1520
Some blessings in God's kingdom are only
received through strong and wholehearted
cue-1521
seeking.
cue-1522
A minister once told of a Sunday school
teacher who had become discouraged with
cue-1523
his class and wanted to give it up.
cue-1524
The superintendent urged him to try once
more and asked him to promise that for
cue-1525
three months he would pray privately every
day for each boy in the class.
cue-1526
Every boy in that class was converted, and
four of them later became
cue-1527
ministers who were greatly used by God.
cue-1528
Chapter Ten:
cue-1529
The Reward of Prayer.
cue-1530
"Your Father who sees in secret will
reward you."
cue-1531
Jesus did not hesitate to connect prayer
with reward.
cue-1532
And who can measure the blessings that
come through prayer?
cue-1533
Even those who deny that prayer changes
outward circumstances often still
cue-1534
admit that it changes the person who
prays.
cue-1535
The value of a daily habit of withdrawing
from the world and meeting God in
cue-1536
private is impossible to overstate.
cue-1537
To think about eternal things, to turn the
mind toward what cannot be seen,
cue-1538
and to honestly seek fellowship with God
rescues life from being
cue-1539
restless, worried, and empty.
cue-1540
Even apart from specific answers, the
influence of regular private prayer is
cue-1541
beyond measure.
cue-1542
I want to consider three, perhaps four,
examples.
cue-1543
It has been said that the mountains of the
Bible richly reward anyone who climbs
cue-1544
them,
cue-1545
and no life in scripture is more filled
with mountain scenes than the life of
cue-1546
Moses.
cue-1547
For forty years, he wandered among lonely
mountains, tending his flock and wrestling
cue-1548
with great questions about his people and
about God.
cue-1549
He had been educated in all the wisdom of
Egypt, but when God wanted to teach him,
cue-1550
he brought him out of the valley and up
into the mountain.
cue-1551
It was there in the silence of those
ancient heights that the polished man of
cue-1552
the court and the learned scholar was
prepared for the work of leading and
cue-1553
delivering God's people.
cue-1554
His service both began and ended on the
mountain. Before every new
cue-1555
step and at every great crisis, God called
him upwards, and he
cue-1556
wentWhenever the burden of his calling
became too heavy, he
cue-1557
hurried to seek God on the mountain.
cue-1558
What he found there is still a wonder to
the world. The mountain of God was a
cue-1559
special place set apart as holy. God
commanded that boundaries be
cue-1560
placed around it so that even cattle
would not wander onto it.
cue-1561
Set bounds around the mountain and make it
holy.
cue-1562
The people were not allowed to come near.
cue-1563
Even priests and elders had to stop at the
boundary.
cue-1564
No companions could go all the way.
cue-1565
Even his closest friends had to remain
behind while the servant of God went
cue-1566
alone into the holy place.
cue-1567
The Lord told Moses to prepare himself and
come up early in the morning.
cue-1568
God wants a person at his best. All these
instructions in the books of
cue-1569
Moses point forward to the teaching of
Jesus in the Sermon on the Mount.
cue-1570
There is a special sense in which God is
present in the secret place.
cue-1571
He is there in secret, and he sees in
secret.
cue-1572
God calls us up to the mountain. Come
away. Come up. Come up
cue-1573
early. Before sunrise, both Jesus and
Moses were alone with God.
cue-1574
Let us go up with Moses and learn what he
found on the mountain of God.
cue-1575
The place of revelation.
cue-1576
Moses found God on the mountain.
cue-1577
Read the story in Exodus three.
cue-1578
After forty years of exile because he had
tried to help God's people,
cue-1579
this shepherd prince came to know the God
of Israel in a personal way.
cue-1580
He was not completely unfamiliar with God
while he was still in Egypt.
cue-1581
He had already turned away from the
privileges and pleasures of the royal
cue-1582
palace
cue-1583
and chosen to stand with the suffering
people of his own race.
cue-1584
He had shown great zeal for God, but he
had never received a personal revelation
cue-1585
of him until that day on the mountain.
cue-1586
Many people serve God in outward ways.
cue-1587
Many work and suffer for Him, yet never
enter the holy place of close fellowship
cue-1588
where God makes Himself known.
cue-1589
It is there in secret that He reveals
Himself in a way He does not reveal
cue-1590
Himself to those who have no inner place
of prayer.
cue-1591
Moses also discovered himself when he
found God.
cue-1592
That is not always pleasant, and it
usually is not. He was a disappointed
cue-1593
reformer. He had sacrificed much for
Israel only to find the
cue-1594
people resisting him, doubting his
motives, and mistrusting his purpose.
cue-1595
For forty years, he had thought about a
wicked king and a weak,
cue-1596
ungrateful people. He carried his hurt
like a martyr and the
cue-1597
sadness of a failed leader. Then the voice
from the fire said,
cue-1598
"Put your hand inside your cloak."
cue-1599
When he did, his hand became leprous,
white as snow.
cue-1600
This shocked him.
cue-1601
He had thought the problem was in others,
but now he saw that his own heart and
cue-1602
hands were not clean either.
cue-1603
This is the kind of discovery people make
on God's mountain, and one reason why we
cue-1604
are often slow to go there.
cue-1605
But Moses found more than his sin.
cue-1606
He found himself. He found hidden
strength. He found his calling. He
cue-1607
discovered that the staff he carried every
day was a sign and tool of
cue-1608
God's power.
cue-1609
When God reveals Himself to us, He also
reveals us to ourselves.
cue-1610
Moses found the will of God on the
mountain.
cue-1611
There he received the law. After forty
days alone with God, he came
cue-1612
down carrying heaven's laws on two stone
tablets.
cue-1613
Those laws still stand as the foundation
of just government among
cue-1614
people. Even after many centuries, they
remain basic to
cue-1615
civilization.
cue-1616
He received not only the commandments that
would guide human life for all time, but
cue-1617
also detailed instructions for daily
matters.
cue-1618
Look at the directions for building the
tabernacle.
cue-1619
Nothing was too small to matter.
cue-1620
Nails, fringes, tongs, and snuffers were
all included. Every
cue-1621
detail was planned on the mountain. Every
pattern was fixed and approved by
cue-1622
God.
cue-1623
The way to the mountain is still open. The
pattern for each life can still be seen
cue-1624
in the secret place with God.
cue-1625
Even the humblest follower of Jesus may
know God's will directly.
cue-1626
Every believer has the privilege of being
fully sure of God's will.
cue-1627
God's attention to detail is amazing.
cue-1628
Nothing is too small for His wisdom.
cue-1629
Go straight to Him. Do not depend first on
other people.
cue-1630
Bring every question openly before Him,
and He will make His will clear to you.
cue-1631
When God speaks, His voice is plain enough
to understand.
cue-1632
Questions that belong to daily life should
be settled on the mountain
cue-1633
because when there is certainty with God
in the secret place,
cue-1634
there will be victory in ordinary life and
in difficult places too.
cue-1635
The place of power.
cue-1636
There is a striking story in Exodus
seventeen.
cue-1637
It tells of Israel's first battle.
cue-1638
The Amalekites attacked them at Rephidim.
cue-1639
Joshua led the army in the field while
Moses went up the mountain to pray.
cue-1640
The battle changed back and forth in a
remarkable way.
cue-1641
First, one side seemed to win, then the
other.
cue-1642
At last, it became clear that the outcome
did not depend mainly on the soldiers
cue-1643
below,
cue-1644
but on the prayer of those above.
cue-1645
The unarmed hand of prayer ruled the
battle,
cue-1646
and whenever Moses held up his hand,
Israel prevailed, and whenever he lowered
cue-1647
his hand, Amalek prevailed.
cue-1648
The lesson is clear.
cue-1649
Power is one reward of prayer.It takes us
a long time to
cue-1650
learn that prayer is more important than
organization,
cue-1651
more powerful than armies, more
influential than wealth, and stronger than
cue-1652
human learning.
cue-1653
Prayer that prevails makes people
unconquerable. Those who prevail in the
cue-1654
secret place with God cannot truly be
defeated anywhere.
cue-1655
All things are possible through secret
prayer.
cue-1656
The place of fellowship.
cue-1657
On the mountain, the Lord spoke with Moses
face to face as a man speaks with his
cue-1658
friend.
cue-1659
Like Abraham, Moses was brought into
friendship with God.
cue-1660
He did not come only to make requests or
receive commands.
cue-1661
He came for fellowship, for close
communion with God.
cue-1662
The inner room of prayer is like a place
where the soul meets God in friendship and
cue-1663
open sharing.
cue-1664
It is a place for listening as well as
speaking.
cue-1665
The most important part of prayer is not
only what we say to God, but what God
cue-1666
says to us.
cue-1667
It is not a place for hurry.
cue-1668
The soul must become quiet and wait before
the Lord.
cue-1669
The mountain is also the place of
intercession.
cue-1670
Exodus thirty-two, verses nine to fourteen
tells how Moses pleaded for
cue-1671
Israel. He stood in the gap for the
people.
cue-1672
God looks for those who will do this.
cue-1673
Ezekiel twenty-two thirty says that he
looks for someone to stand in the breach.
cue-1674
God invites us to speak for others and
plead on their behalf.
cue-1675
He allows himself to be approached in this
way.
cue-1676
How bold Abraham was in prayer. How
courageously Moses stood before
cue-1677
God and pleaded for Israel.
cue-1678
How deeply Paul prayed for his fellow
Jews.
cue-1679
We are commanded to pray for one another,
and no one can fully measure the blessings
cue-1680
that come through intercession.
cue-1681
It was on the mountain that Moses saw
God's glory.
cue-1682
This is also part of the secret place of
prayer.
cue-1683
It was on a mountain that Jesus was
transfigured. The glory seen there is also
cue-1684
shared. Prayer changes us.
cue-1685
When Moses came down from the mountain,
his face was shining, though he did not
cue-1686
know it. That is the secret of true
humility with glory.
cue-1687
When Jesus prayed, he was transfigured
before them.
cue-1688
Glory is another reward of prayer. The
Lord who calls his servant up the
cue-1689
mountain also sends him back down again.
Peter wanted to remain on the
cue-1690
mountain, but we go up so that we may come
back down. There are idols
cue-1691
to confront, sinful passions to overcome,
confused people to help,
cue-1692
troubled fathers and broken sons and
daughters who need the vision and
cue-1693
power of God.
cue-1694
Come up, then go down.
cue-1695
God wants us on the mountain, and he also
wants us in the valley.
cue-1696
Moses died on the mountain.
cue-1697
Those who go up and down at God's command
will one day go up at last and never
cue-1698
come down again.
cue-1699
Chapter eleven:
cue-1700
The power of prayer.
cue-1701
In the New Testament, Elijah is chosen as
the example of prayer. Many people in the
cue-1702
Old Testament prayed and received powerful
answers from God. The scriptures are full
cue-1703
of stories of those who called on God and
were delivered.
cue-1704
Jacob prayed so earnestly that his name
was changed from Jacob to Israel.
cue-1705
Moses was especially a man of prayer.
Through it, he was sustained, guided,
cue-1706
and changed. Daniel prayed regularly and
faithfully, and
cue-1707
his life was deeply shaped by prayer.
cue-1708
There were many others as well, from
Abraham to the last of the prophets,
cue-1709
including kings, priests, soldiers,
reformers, widows, and
cue-1710
those who suffered.
cue-1711
So why was Elijah chosen from among them
all?
cue-1712
A mighty man.
cue-1713
Elijah is given greater importance in the
New Testament than in the Old, and it
cue-1714
is always helpful when the New Testament
explains something from the Old.
cue-1715
In the Old Testament, we are told what
Elijah did, but not clearly where his
cue-1716
power came from.
cue-1717
His life was marked by sudden dramatic
appearances, and it ended in a remarkable
cue-1718
way.
cue-1719
He lived mostly alone and often felt
alone, saying, "I alone."
cue-1720
The Old Testament ends with a promise that
he would return, and the New Testament
cue-1721
begins by showing that this promise was
fulfilled.
cue-1722
Elijah stood for God, challenged kings,
and influenced the fate of
cue-1723
nations.
cue-1724
The New Testament explains his life and
power in a simple way.
cue-1725
He was a man of prayer.
cue-1726
In the Old Testament, prayer is clearly
part of his life, but the New Testament
cue-1727
shows that prayer was the whole reason for
who he was and what he did.
cue-1728
He was a great man, but he had the same
human struggles as others.
cue-1729
What made him different was prayer.
cue-1730
As Epistle of James says,
cue-1731
"Elijah was a man just like us, and he
prayed."
cue-1732
Prayer explains Elijah's life just as it
explains the lives of Abraham,
cue-1733
Jacob, David, and Daniel.
cue-1734
Yet there was something especially
powerful about Elijah's prayers that set
cue-1735
him apart even among those who prayed
greatly.
cue-1736
What was it?
cue-1737
Why did people come to know God as the
Lord God of Elijah?
cue-1738
Miracles of power.
cue-1739
Elijah's prayers show the supernatural
power of prayer.
cue-1740
His prayers were acts of power, true
miracles.
cue-1741
This is how the New Testament describes
them. There has been some difficulty in
cue-1742
translating James five sixteen.The older
version says,
cue-1743
"The effectual fervent prayer of a
righteous man avails much."
cue-1744
Another version says,
cue-1745
"The prayer of a righteous man is powerful
in its working."
cue-1746
Dr. Rendell Harris translates it as,
cue-1747
"The energized prayer of a righteous man
is very powerful."
cue-1748
For Elijah, prayer was not just words, it
was power.
cue-1749
It was supernatural and worked in
miraculous ways.
cue-1750
He did not debate about natural laws, and
he never doubted God's power to act
cue-1751
beyond them. He simply prayed. When he
prayed, the rain
cue-1752
stopped. When he prayed again, the rain
came in abundance.
cue-1753
When he prayed for the widow's dead child,
the child came back to life.
cue-1754
When he prayed for fire from heaven, it
came down.
cue-1755
Elijah did not argue about prayer, he
practiced it.
cue-1756
The best way to understand prayer is to
pray.
cue-1757
There have always been questions about
prayer.
cue-1758
In the wilderness, people questioned
whether God could act beyond the known
cue-1759
laws of the world.
cue-1760
Can God do this?
cue-1761
Faith answers, "Yes, He can."
cue-1762
These are not days when we can easily say
anything is impossible.
cue-1763
We are discovering new things all the
time.
cue-1764
If people can now do what once seemed
impossible, who can say that anything is
cue-1765
impossible for God?
cue-1766
If human thoughts can be sent and heard
across great distances,
cue-1767
who can limit the thoughts and purposes of
God?
cue-1768
God, who made heaven and Earth, must be
greater than His creation.
cue-1769
He cannot be limited by the laws He made.
cue-1770
The prayer of faith connects a person's
request with God's power.
cue-1771
Most people believe prayer can influence
the mind, shape character, and purify
cue-1772
motives and desires,
cue-1773
but prayer is more than that.
cue-1774
Prayer is power.
cue-1775
Prayer changes things.
cue-1776
The Lord God of Elijah has complete and
unlimited power, and this power
cue-1777
responds to believing prayer. Everyone who
truly prays has seen
cue-1778
answers that can only be explained by God.
I hesitate to give
cue-1779
examples, but in my own life, there are
many.
cue-1780
Because of this, the words of Psalm 116
are often in my
cue-1781
heart. "I love the Lord because He has
heard my voice and
cue-1782
my pleas for mercy.
cue-1783
Because He turned His ear to me, I will
call on Him as long as I live."
cue-1784
There is one remarkable example I value
deeply because of how I heard it.
cue-1785
In the city of Bristol, there are two
buildings that stand as reminders of
cue-1786
answered prayer.
cue-1787
One is the orphanage founded by George
Muller. The other I am not free to speak
cue-1788
about here.
cue-1789
Arthur Tappan Pearson, who was both my
friend and Muller's biographer, told me
cue-1790
part of this story. He once stayed with
Muller at the orphanage.
cue-1791
One night, after everyone had gone to bed,
Muller asked him to pray with him.
cue-1792
He explained that there was no food at all
for breakfast the next morning. Pearson
cue-1793
tried to object and reminded him that all
the stores were closed.
cue-1794
Muller already knew that.
cue-1795
He had prayed as he always did, and he
never told anyone his needs
cue-1796
except God.
cue-1797
So they prayed,
cue-1798
Muller with strong faith and Pearson doing
his best.
cue-1799
They went to bed and slept.
cue-1800
In the morning, there was enough food
prepared to feed 2,000 children just as
cue-1801
usual. Neither Muller nor Pearson knew how
the answer
cue-1802
came. The rest of the story was told the
next morning to a man named
cue-1803
Simon Short,
cue-1804
who promised to keep it secret until the
giver had died.
cue-1805
During the night, God had awakened him and
led him to send food to the orphanage.
cue-1806
He knew nothing of the need or of the two
men praying,
cue-1807
yet he sent enough supplies to feed them
for a month.
cue-1808
This is what God is like, the same God who
answered Elijah, and even more,
cue-1809
the God and Father of our Lord Jesus
Christ.
cue-1810
The greatest force on Earth.
cue-1811
Not every kind of prayer brings such
powerful results. It takes a true man or
cue-1812
woman of prayer to pray like Elijah and
George Muller.
cue-1813
It is the prayer of a righteous person
filled with God's power that has great
cue-1814
effect.
cue-1815
The widow recognized Elijah as a man of
God when he prayed, and her son came back
cue-1816
to life.
cue-1817
This is the highest proof and the final
test.
cue-1818
Nothing would bring people back to God
more quickly than a church that truly
cue-1819
prays and sees answers.
cue-1820
The world will not believe in a faith that
has no supernatural power.
cue-1821
A faith that is only intellectual, a
church focused only on social work,
cue-1822
or a message reduced to moral teaching may
receive praise,
cue-1823
but they do not deeply convince people or
lead them to true change.
cue-1824
There is deep passion in prayer that truly
succeeds.
cue-1825
Elijah was a man full of strong feeling
and intensity.
cue-1826
Everything he did, he did with his whole
heart.
cue-1827
God delights in people who are fully
committed. He cannot accept
cue-1828
half-heartedness. He does not delay when
people seek Him with all their heart.
cue-1829
As it is written in Book of Jeremiah
29:13-14, "When people
cue-1830
search for God with all their heart, they
will find Him."
cue-1831
When Elijah prayed, he was fully engaged
in his prayer.
cue-1832
Is it not true that much praying today
lacks real prayer?
cue-1833
A true man of prayer puts his whole self
into what he asks.We see
cue-1834
this in Elijah when he prayed over the
dead child on Mount Carmel, and when he
cue-1835
cried out to God for the people and for
God's honor. This same
cue-1836
passion is seen throughout Scripture:
cue-1837
Abraham pleading for Sodom, Jacob
wrestling through the night, Moses
cue-1838
standing between God and the people,
cue-1839
Hannah pouring out her sorrow,
cue-1840
David broken with repentance, and even
Jesus praying with such
cue-1841
intensity that it was like sweating blood.
cue-1842
If we add examples from church history and
personal experience, the pattern is
cue-1843
always the same.
cue-1844
True prayer involves deep cost and strong
passion, and it brings
cue-1845
results. It changes ordinary people into
people of power. It
cue-1846
brings power, fire, rain, life. It brings
God near.
cue-1847
There is no power like the power of prayer
that truly prevails.
cue-1848
Recent letters have shared many stories of
answered prayer.
cue-1849
I understand why some people question
them. Those who have not gone through
cue-1850
deep, earnest prayer can often look for
other explanations.
cue-1851
But for the one who has truly prayed, any
explanation only increases the
cue-1852
wonder of the answer.
cue-1853
In a real sense, he receives the answer in
his heart before it appears outwardly.
cue-1854
Consider one example.
cue-1855
A man told me about a serious problem in
his business.
cue-1856
Like Jehoshaphat, he had no resources to
meet the need and did not know what to
cue-1857
do.
cue-1858
Still, he continued praying earnestly to
God.
cue-1859
Then one day, a deep peace filled his
heart, and he knew that God had heard
cue-1860
him. Nothing around him had changed, yet
he was certain of the answer.
cue-1861
Later, in a completely unexpected way, and
through someone not well known to him,
cue-1862
help came. The situation could be
explained in ordinary
cue-1863
terms, but the answer to prayer was just
as real and
cue-1864
certain. It seems to me that arguing about
prayer is useless.
cue-1865
A challenge like that of Thomas Henry
Huxley leads nowhere.
cue-1866
The proof that God answers prayer is found
in praying.
cue-1867
Once, I responded to a man who challenged
me to prove that God answers prayer.
cue-1868
I asked him to kneel and pray,
cue-1869
but he refused. I still believe this is
the only true way to know,
cue-1870
and it is both practical and certain.
cue-1871
Another story, which I can share, comes
from T. A. Turney.
cue-1872
As a boy, he attended a school where the
teacher was also his uncle.
cue-1873
The teacher was strict and made students
discover answers for themselves.
cue-1874
To avoid showing favoritism, he was even
harder on his nephew.
cue-1875
The boy came to a point where he could not
solve a math problem. Day after day,
cue-1876
he brought it to his teacher, only to be
told to try again.
cue-1877
This continued for more than a week. One
night, the boy went to a church service
cue-1878
and gave his life to God.
cue-1879
As he knelt in prayer, he later asked God
to help him with the problem.
cue-1880
That night, whether asleep or awake, he
saw the solution clearly worked
cue-1881
out.
cue-1882
He got up and wrote it down.
cue-1883
The next morning, he showed it to his
teacher.
cue-1884
The teacher looked at it and said,
"Correct. Who showed you?"
cue-1885
"God," the boy replied.
cue-1886
An energized intercessor.
cue-1887
Have you heard of John Hyde?
cue-1888
He came to be known as Praying Hyde by
those who knew him well.
cue-1889
This began after he experienced a deep
spiritual renewal,
cue-1890
often described as the baptism of the Holy
Spirit.
cue-1891
From that time, his remarkable life of
prayer truly began.
cue-1892
The recorded answers to his prayers are
only a small part of his story. He prayed
cue-1893
the Indian Keswick movement into being.
cue-1894
He prayed for thousands to come to faith
in God and for hundreds of workers to go
cue-1895
out into God's harvest fields.
cue-1896
More than all this, he grew into a deep
sharing in the intercession of our Lord.
cue-1897
The secret of his prayer life was simple:
his whole life was devoted to prayer.
cue-1898
In 1911, John Hyde was in England. He
attended a mission where J. Wilbur
cue-1899
Chapman and Charles Alexander were
struggling.
cue-1900
Hyde took the burden of the meetings upon
himself and prayed until there was a clear
cue-1901
breakthrough. After a powerful meeting,
Dr. Chapman asked
cue-1902
Hyde to pray for him.
cue-1903
This is how he described it.
cue-1904
He came into my room, locked the door, and
knelt down.
cue-1905
For five minutes, he said nothing.
cue-1906
I could hear both our hearts beating.
cue-1907
Tears ran down my face, and I knew I was
in God's presence.
cue-1908
Then he softly said,
cue-1909
"Oh, God,"
cue-1910
and again was silent for several minutes.
When he began to pray, he put his
cue-1911
arm around me, and from deep within came
prayers for people that I had never heard
cue-1912
before.
cue-1913
When I rose from my knees,
cue-1914
I understood what real prayer was.
cue-1915
We had believed prayer was powerful, but
now we knew it in a new way.
cue-1916
I know that stories like this can
discourage some people,
cue-1917
even though they are meant to inspire. I
am not saying that we must become
cue-1918
like these exceptional individuals,
cue-1919
but I do rejoice in this truth.
cue-1920
Whatever God gave to them is also
available to all.
cue-1921
Chapter Twelve:
cue-1922
Praying and the Commonplace.
cue-1923
Moses and Elijah were not ordinary men.
They were so unique that, out of
cue-1924
all the Old Testament saints, they were
chosen to speak with Jesus on the Mount of
cue-1925
Transfiguration.One led under the old
covenant, and the other
cue-1926
was its most powerful prophet.
cue-1927
Their roles were special.
cue-1928
God called them to tasks that required
close and constant fellowship with Him.
cue-1929
Miracles were clearly seen in everything
they did.
cue-1930
The staff of Moses and the cloak of Elijah
showed God's power at work.
cue-1931
Their prayers brought about miracles. They
lived in the presence of God's unlimited
cue-1932
power.
cue-1933
Through their words, the heavens and the
earth were affected.
cue-1934
Rivers and rain obeyed them. Life and
death were under their command. Oil
cue-1935
and flour were multiplied.
cue-1936
Even greater than these visible miracles
were the results of their prayers in
cue-1937
receiving understanding and direction.
cue-1938
God revealed His thoughts to them and
showed them His will. In answer to their
cue-1939
prayers, they received wisdom beyond human
understanding. These
cue-1940
works of the mind were greater than
miracles over physical things.
cue-1941
Prayer and ordinary people.
cue-1942
The powerful stories of answered prayer in
the Bible have deeply shaped how ordinary
cue-1943
people think.
cue-1944
They have set miracles as the normal way
prayer works.
cue-1945
This is true in one sense because all
prayer is supernatural.
cue-1946
Yet this idea can also discourage people.
Moses was unique,
cue-1947
and although Elijah had human struggles
like we do,
cue-1948
he was not an ordinary man, and his
mission was far from
cue-1949
common. So what place does prayer have in
the lives of ordinary people?
cue-1950
What about those who have no quiet time or
free moments, and whose days are filled
cue-1951
with repetitive, everyday tasks?
cue-1952
Is prayer only for special people in
unusual situations,
cue-1953
or does it also belong in the lives of
those with simple abilities and ordinary
cue-1954
routines?
cue-1955
About the New Testament prophet who
followed Elijah, it is said that he
cue-1956
performed no miracles. He was just as
devoted to
cue-1957
prayer, but he did not multiply food,
raise the dead, or
cue-1958
control nature.
cue-1959
The only miracles seen in him were in his
character, his insight, and his
cue-1960
message.
cue-1961
This shows that God's power can work
through normal, everyday life.
cue-1962
Ordinary people can pray about ordinary
things, and the answers may come as a
cue-1963
clearer mind, a joyful and strong spirit,
steady faith, and a
cue-1964
holy life. There may be no dramatic
events, but prayer
cue-1965
lifts even the simplest life into the
realm of God's power,
cue-1966
and that is the greatest miracle of all.
cue-1967
Prayer and daily work.
cue-1968
It is clear that we can't all be like
Elijah or Elisha, Abraham or Daniel,
cue-1969
or even people like George Muller, Hudson
Taylor, Barnardo, or Praying Hyde.
cue-1970
But that does not mean we can't be people
of prayer.
cue-1971
In scripture, there are those who prayed,
yet no miracles are recorded about them.
cue-1972
They lived and worked in ordinary
settings.
cue-1973
Jacob and Moses were shepherds with long
periods of quiet where they could pray.
cue-1974
Elijah, it seems, did little else but
pray.
cue-1975
His life of miracles should be balanced
with the lives of others who worked under
cue-1976
normal conditions.
cue-1977
We expect preachers and prophets to devote
themselves to prayer,
cue-1978
but what about those who work in
factories, offices, and stores?
cue-1979
Nehemiah was just as much a man of prayer
as Elijah.
cue-1980
He was a builder working to restore the
wall of Jerusalem.
cue-1981
He performed no miracles, saw no visions,
and had no special message directly
cue-1982
from heaven.
cue-1983
He never claimed that God sent him, nor
did he ask others to say so.
cue-1984
Instead, he saw a need and had an
opportunity,
cue-1985
and that was enough.
cue-1986
The broken state of the city filled him
with sorrow.
cue-1987
There was important work to be done, and
no one seemed ready to do it. He
cue-1988
felt deeply that he should take
responsibility,
cue-1989
so he prayed.
cue-1990
He prayed when he heard the bad news. He
prayed for the ruined city, for the
cue-1991
suffering people, and for their shame. He
prayed until his heart was
cue-1992
almost breaking.
cue-1993
Nothing dramatic seemed to happen. No
angel appeared.
cue-1994
God gave no visible sign.
cue-1995
When Elijah prayed, outward things
changed. When Nehemiah prayed,
cue-1996
it seemed like nothing happened.
cue-1997
But something did happen. Something
changed within Nehemiah,
cue-1998
and a changed person is a greater miracle
than changes in nature.
cue-1999
His sorrow led him to prayer.
cue-2000
Prayer formed a deep conviction.
Conviction gave him purpose.
cue-2001
Purpose drove his energy. Energy led to
action. And so these two
cue-2002
truths come together.
cue-2003
"So I prayed, and so we built."
cue-2004
Nehemiah's prayers did not produce sudden
or dramatic displays of supernatural
cue-2005
power,
cue-2006
yet they led to the rebuilding of the wall
and the restoration of the city.
cue-2007
This was the work God had given him.
cue-2008
Nehemiah prayed about his work.
cue-2009
Prayer was not occasional for him. It was
his constant attitude and daily habit.
cue-2010
Some people only pray in special or
desperate situations.
cue-2011
We hear of those who pray when they are
completely overwhelmed.
cue-2012
Many people only turn to prayer at such
times.
cue-2013
Others pray only when they feel strong
emotions.
cue-2014
But Nehemiah prayed continually
cue-2015
through every step and about everything.
cue-2016
Prayer was so natural to him that it
shaped his whole life
cue-2017
until he truly became a man of prayer.
cue-2018
The practical value of prayer.The habit of
prayer
cue-2019
shapes how a person sees life.
cue-2020
It begins with the belief that God is real
and rules over everything. It
cue-2021
brings all things under His will, brings
every matter before Him, judges
cue-2022
everything by His standards, and lives in
trust toward Him.
cue-2023
Prayer is both the heart and the test of a
godly life.
cue-2024
Who can fully measure how prayer affects
the mind and shapes character?
cue-2025
Who can estimate its value in giving
wisdom and skill for daily life?
cue-2026
The Book of Nehemiah shows this clearly.
It records what prayer did in the life of
cue-2027
a man who performed no miracles, yet
rebuilt the wall in the face
cue-2028
of great opposition. Through prayer,
Nehemiah gained the king's
cue-2029
approval and support,
cue-2030
as well as all the supplies he needed.
cue-2031
Prayer gave him courage and good judgment
when facing critics and enemies.
cue-2032
It helped him deal wisely with problems
among the workers, including matters of
cue-2033
labor and wages.
cue-2034
It protected him from deceitful officials
and gave him insight to resist the
cue-2035
schemes of his enemies.
cue-2036
When false accusations were made against
him, prayer became his
cue-2037
refuge. It equipped him not only with
faith, but also with a steady
cue-2038
spirit,
cue-2039
even a sense of calm confidence as he
worked with both sword and tool
cue-2040
in hand.
cue-2041
He kept his life clean, his mind sharp,
and his courage strong,
cue-2042
praying through every challenge.
cue-2043
He was confident in God, confident in
God's character, God's Word, and
cue-2044
God's covenant,
cue-2045
so he prayed, and he trusted. He worked,
and he overcame.
cue-2046
Whatever you ask.
cue-2047
There is nothing we can't pray about, but
prayer is not effective if it is only a
cue-2048
passing desire or careless wish.
cue-2049
Nehemiah prayed about his work, but he
also made it his business to understand it
cue-2050
well. His work succeeded because he gave
himself fully to it.
cue-2051
It does no good to pray about work and
then neglect it or act foolishly in it
cue-2052
through lack of courage, skill, or wisdom.
cue-2053
Nehemiah prayed, but he also used good
judgment.
cue-2054
He trusted God to provide, yet he made
sure to obtain the king's letters.
cue-2055
He trusted God to protect, yet he
equipped the builders with
cue-2056
both tools and weapons.
cue-2057
Prayer gives clear vision in private,
understanding in action, wisdom in
cue-2058
decisions, courage in testing, strength to
endure hardship, and
cue-2059
a deep joy in following God's will.
cue-2060
There was once a weaver who prayed over
his work as Nehemiah did.
cue-2061
People came to say that every piece of
cloth he made was for the Lord Jesus
cue-2062
Christ.
cue-2063
He never became rich, but his work
succeeded, and his character was of
cue-2064
great value. Every task and duty can be
made holy through God's
cue-2065
Word and prayer.
cue-2066
A life of prayer that shows no outward
miracles may, in fact, be the
cue-2067
greatest miracle of all.
cue-2068
The secret of life is found in the quiet
place where God waits.
cue-2069
Even for those who cannot find outward
privacy,
cue-2070
there is an inner place of the soul where
they can withdraw.
cue-2071
The habit of private prayer is of great
and lasting value. There is nothing that
cue-2072
should not be brought to God in prayer.
cue-2073
Life can be lived before Him. Problems can
be worked through in His presence.
cue-2074
Questions about both freedom and duty can
be settled there. God's guidance
cue-2075
can be sought, and everything can be
placed under His judgment.
cue-2076
This inner place becomes a sanctuary for
the soul.
cue-2077
One morning, there was a beautiful sight,
cue-2078
a rainbow rising over the hill. It stood
bright and full,
cue-2079
then stretched until one end touched the
village and the other reached the
cue-2080
river.
cue-2081
Its colors were beyond description,
filling the whole scene with beauty.
cue-2082
The old ruins looked like a palace, and
every small house seemed to shine.
cue-2083
Fields and trees reflected the light, and
even the simplest objects appeared
cue-2084
full of beauty and glory.
cue-2085
In the same way, prayer makes ordinary
life holy and beautiful.
cue-2086
It brings God's presence into everyday
things and fills even the simplest life
cue-2087
with meaning and glory.
cue-2088
Chapter thirteen:
cue-2089
The prayer of faith.
cue-2090
He who comes to God must believe that He
exists and that He rewards those who
cue-2091
earnestly seek Him.
cue-2092
Faith is necessary for prayer.
cue-2093
Without it, it is hard to see how anyone
could truly pray.
cue-2094
No one can pray without some measure of
faith.
cue-2095
That is why the faith God requires is the
first condition in a person who
cue-2096
prays.
cue-2097
Atheists do not pray.
cue-2098
God places great value on faith.
cue-2099
He makes it the first requirement for
prayer, the only condition for salvation,
cue-2100
the essential part of spiritual life, and
the foundation of all true power.
cue-2101
It is a shallow understanding of faith
that mocks salvation by grace through
cue-2102
faith alone.
cue-2103
Faith is enough.
cue-2104
It is all God asks and all Jesus asks.
"You believe in God,
cue-2105
believe also in me."
cue-2106
When the synagogue leader was told his
daughter had died,
cue-2107
Jesus encouraged him saying, "Do not be
afraid. Only
cue-2108
believe."And when the troubled father of a
possessed boy cried out in
cue-2109
despair,
cue-2110
Jesus assured him that all things are
possible for the one who believes.
cue-2111
Without faith, it is impossible to please
God.
cue-2112
Without faith, it is impossible to pray.
Without faith, there can be
cue-2113
no fellowship with God.
cue-2114
Without faith, a person can do nothing
with God, and God does nothing
cue-2115
with that person.
cue-2116
Even in human life, nothing works without
faith.
cue-2117
Faith is the foundation, not only of
salvation, but also of everyday
cue-2118
life and human society.
cue-2119
The law of faith.
cue-2120
The Apostle Paul explains the law of faith
in relation to grace, and James
cue-2121
explains the same law in relation to
prayer.
cue-2122
There is no conflict between them.
cue-2123
For both,
cue-2124
faith is more than simply agreeing with
something in the mind,
cue-2125
no matter how sincere that agreement may
be.
cue-2126
Faith is a moral and spiritual response
that commits the whole person to
cue-2127
truth that is accepted and trusted. It is
more than belief.
cue-2128
Even evil spirits believe and tremble, but
they do not
cue-2129
trust. Faith is trust.
cue-2130
It is not just an opinion, an idea, or a
guess.
cue-2131
It is a way of seeing, a means of
confirming truth, a confident knowledge,
cue-2132
and a guiding principle for life.
cue-2133
True faith requires an honest mind, pure
motives, and faithful
cue-2134
obedience.
cue-2135
This kind of faith works according to
God's order. It brings justification to
cue-2136
the sinner, holiness to the unholy, and
power in prayer.
cue-2137
Jesus said that even faith as small as a
mustard seed can move mountains,
cue-2138
that nothing will be impossible.
cue-2139
Yet he also taught that such power is
connected with prayer and fasting.
cue-2140
This teaching should be understood
alongside his words:
cue-2141
"Have faith in God.
cue-2142
Whoever speaks to a mountain and does not
doubt but believes it will happen will
cue-2143
receive what he asks."
cue-2144
Therefore, when we pray, we are to believe
that we have received what we ask for,
cue-2145
and it will be given.
cue-2146
The law of faith in prayer.
cue-2147
One,
cue-2148
ask, James one-five.
cue-2149
James follows and explains the teaching of
Jesus, especially from the Sermon on the
cue-2150
Mount. He begins simply, "Ask. If anyone
lacks, let him ask
cue-2151
God."
cue-2152
This invitation includes every kind of
need, not only wisdom.
cue-2153
God gives freely to all who ask without
blaming or holding back.
cue-2154
So the promise stands,
cue-2155
ask and you will receive.
cue-2156
Prayer has no narrow limits.
cue-2157
Whatever is promised to whoever, giving
full freedom to those who pray.
cue-2158
We are told not to be anxious about
anything, but to bring everything to God
cue-2159
in prayer with thanksgiving. God already
knows our
cue-2160
needs, but asking is not about informing
Him. It is about coming to Him in
cue-2161
trust.
cue-2162
God waits to be asked so that He may give
what we truly need.
cue-2163
Two,
cue-2164
ask in faith, James one-six.
cue-2165
Faith is best understood by looking at its
opposite, doubt.
cue-2166
Doubt makes a person divided and unstable.
cue-2167
Like the sea, it is restless and easily
driven by winds and waves.
cue-2168
Inner struggles disturb it, and outward
circumstances push it in different
cue-2169
directions.
cue-2170
Such a person receives nothing because
they are not fully committed.
cue-2171
A divided mind leads to an unsteady life.
As it has been
cue-2172
said, "Ships go east and ships go west,
whatever the winds that
cue-2173
blow.
cue-2174
The set of the sail and not the gale
settles the way we go."
cue-2175
Faith sets the sails.
cue-2176
Three,
cue-2177
ask in the right way,
cue-2178
James four-three.
cue-2179
It is possible to ask wrongly.
cue-2180
You ask and do not receive because you ask
with wrong motives to spend it on your
cue-2181
own desires.
cue-2182
God looks not only at what we ask for, but
also at why we ask.
cue-2183
He examines the heart.
cue-2184
There are conditions that hinder prayer.
cue-2185
Sin blocks the way.
cue-2186
If I hold on to sin in my heart, the Lord
will not hear me.
cue-2187
Unbelief also blocks the way.
cue-2188
A lack of faith keeps a person from
receiving.
cue-2189
An unforgiving spirit is another barrier.
cue-2190
If we refuse to forgive others, we close
the door on our own prayers.
cue-2191
A divided and unstable mind also prevents
answers.
cue-2192
A guilty conscience can hold us back, and
selfish motives can keep us from
cue-2193
receiving.
cue-2194
Faith works within those who pray so that
they may ask in the right way,
cue-2195
with clean hearts, steady trust, and right
desires.
cue-2196
Four,
cue-2197
ask righteously,
cue-2198
James five-thirteen to eighteen.
cue-2199
Right praying depends on the character of
the one who prays.
cue-2200
The person is, in a sense, the prayer.
cue-2201
He is both the one who asks and the reason
for the asking.
cue-2202
In scripture, many appealed to their
uprightness before God, and their prayers
cue-2203
were heard.
cue-2204
Cornelius is an example. His prayers and
acts of kindness were accepted by
cue-2205
God.
cue-2206
Peter then understood that God does not
show favoritism, but accepts anyone
cue-2207
who fears Him and lives rightly. The
prayers of a righteous person have
cue-2208
great power.
cue-2209
Faith does not replace right living. It
does not cover sin.
cue-2210
Only Christ's sacrifice can do that.But
faith does save from sin,
cue-2211
gives victory over it, and makes a person
righteous before God.
cue-2212
Because of this, there is no condemnation.
cue-2213
Instead, there is confidence before God.
cue-2214
This brings assurance in prayer.
cue-2215
When we obey Him and do what pleases Him,
we can ask with boldness, knowing that He
cue-2216
hears and answers.
cue-2217
Five,
cue-2218
ask earnestly.
cue-2219
God promises that He will be found by
those who seek Him with all their heart.
cue-2220
Elijah's prayers were powerful because
they were full of deep feeling and strong
cue-2221
desire.
cue-2222
Jesus taught through his parables that
prayer should be persistent, continuing
cue-2223
even when it is difficult.
cue-2224
His own prayers were marked by deep cries
and tears.
cue-2225
It is this kind of wholehearted, earnest
prayer that prevails.
cue-2226
Six,
cue-2227
ask in the Spirit. Elijah's effective
prayer was not just emotional.
cue-2228
It was guided and strengthened by the
Holy Spirit.
cue-2229
True prayer is inspired, directed, and
empowered by the Spirit of
cue-2230
God. Seven,
cue-2231
ask in faith.
cue-2232
We must pray with believing hearts
according to the law of faith.
cue-2233
Jesus taught that when we pray, we should
believe we have received what we ask for.
cue-2234
Scripture gives many examples of this kind
of faith.
cue-2235
Hebrews 11 shows how people lived and
acted by faith.
cue-2236
They trusted God's promises even when they
could not yet see the results.
cue-2237
Like the man who believed Jesus' word and
went his way,
cue-2238
they moved forward with confidence.
cue-2239
Israel shouted before the walls of Jericho
fell when there was no visible sign of
cue-2240
change, and their faith brought victory.
cue-2241
Jehoshaphat's singers praised God before
the battle began, and their faith was
cue-2242
stronger than an army.
cue-2243
Elijah spoke God's promise and never-
during a famine, and her supply never ran
cue-2244
out.
cue-2245
The prayer of faith is powerful because it
depends on God's power.
cue-2246
When we pray, we are to believe that we
have received, and it will be given.
cue-2247
God never fails to honor true faith.
cue-2248
Chapter 14:
cue-2249
Praying One for Another.
cue-2250
The people in the Bible who prayed were
often intercessors. They prayed for
cue-2251
others. Abraham prayed for Sodom and
Gomorrah.
cue-2252
Moses prayed for Israel when they turned
away from God.
cue-2253
Samuel prayed through the night for Saul
and continually for the nation.
cue-2254
David prayed for his people. Daniel prayed
for the deliverance of God's people from
cue-2255
captivity. Jesus prayed for his disciples
and especially for Peter.
cue-2256
Paul lived out his teaching that prayers,
intercessions, and thanksgivings should
cue-2257
be made for all people. At one point, it
is said that God was
cue-2258
surprised that no one was praying for
others.
cue-2259
He saw that there was no one to stand in
the gap and intercede.
cue-2260
God's mercy in delivering people is often
connected to those who are willing to
cue-2261
carry the burdens of others in prayer.
cue-2262
God looked for someone to stand before Him
on behalf of the land but
cue-2263
found no one.
cue-2264
This shows that the normal purpose of
prayer is not only for ourselves, but to
cue-2265
intercede, to pray to God for others.
cue-2266
The mystery of intercession.
cue-2267
The mystery of praying for others is one
of the deepest and most beautiful parts of
cue-2268
prayer.
cue-2269
If we do not fully understand how to pray
for ourselves,
cue-2270
how can we know how to pray for others?
cue-2271
We only partly understand our own needs,
cue-2272
so how can we fully understand the needs
of someone else? Who are we to
cue-2273
decide what another person truly needs
before God?
cue-2274
God alone knows, and His knowledge and
love can be trusted.
cue-2275
Yet prayer is not meant to be done alone.
cue-2276
It is personal, but not separate from
others.
cue-2277
Life is connected and dependent on one
another, as it says in Romans 14:7,
cue-2278
"None of us lives to himself."
cue-2279
Prayer can't remain only about our own
needs.
cue-2280
Even when we pray privately, we are still
affected by the people in our homes,
cue-2281
churches, and the world.
cue-2282
The principle of prayer is this:
cue-2283
Each person stands alone before God and is
responsible to Him,
cue-2284
just as each will give an account of
himself.
cue-2285
Each person carries his own burden, yet at
the same time carries the
cue-2286
burdens of others.
cue-2287
There is always a burden to bear.
cue-2288
Praying for others means taking their
needs upon ourselves.
cue-2289
The Savior interceded because He carried
the sins of others, as shown in Isaiah
cue-2290
53:12.
cue-2291
This is true of all prayer for others.
cue-2292
Moses made the troubles of Israel his own
in his prayers, see
cue-2293
Exodus and Numbers.
cue-2294
Isaiah included himself among those with
unclean lips.
cue-2295
Daniel confessed the sins of his nation.
cue-2296
The father of the suffering boy and the
mother of the troubled daughter each made
cue-2297
their child's need their own personal
plea. This has always been
cue-2298
true in the history of the church.
cue-2299
William Carey carried the burden of India,
Hudson Taylor of China, and David
cue-2300
Livingstone of Africa. In the same way,
everyone carries the burden of
cue-2301
those for whom they pray.
cue-2302
The intercession in Heaven.
cue-2303
Prayer is central in Heaven. This is where
the mystery of praying for others begins
cue-2304
to be understood. It is sharing in the
work of our great High Priest at God's
cue-2305
right hand.As Hebrews seven twenty-five
says,
cue-2306
"He always lives to intercede."
cue-2307
It is a mystery that Jesus needed to pray
while He lived on earth.
cue-2308
It is an even greater mystery that He
continues to intercede in heaven.
cue-2309
This is beyond our full understanding. We
cannot fully explain why or
cue-2310
how, but because He lives to intercede, He
is able to completely
cue-2311
save those who come to God through Him.
cue-2312
What is revealed to us is clear and
certain.
cue-2313
The risen Christ is both priest and king
at God's right hand.
cue-2314
As high priest, He represents people
before God.
cue-2315
As king, He represents God to people. He
entered God's
cue-2316
presence by offering Himself as the
sacrifice for sin.
cue-2317
Through His own blood, He became the one
mediator between God and humanity,
cue-2318
and the advocate who speaks to the Father
on our behalf.
cue-2319
He continues to intercede for us.
cue-2320
Our prayers are accepted and made
effective through Him and His finished
cue-2321
work.
cue-2322
He takes the prayers offered on earth and
joins them with the power of heaven,
cue-2323
making them pleasing to God through His
name.
cue-2324
This is what has been revealed to us, and
we should not go beyond it,
cue-2325
but it shows that prayer exists in heaven
as well as on earth.
cue-2326
In the shared life of God's people, prayer
continues, and there is no reason
cue-2327
to think that those who are redeemed are
left out of this work of intercession.
cue-2328
The intercession of the Spirit.
cue-2329
There are two kinds of intercession.
cue-2330
The high priest intercedes for us in
heaven, and the Holy Spirit intercedes
cue-2331
within the temple of the devoted soul.
cue-2332
The Spirit also helps our weaknesses,
cue-2333
for we do not know what we should pray for
as we ought, but the Spirit Himself
cue-2334
intercedes for us with groanings too deep
for words.
cue-2335
And He who searches hearts knows the mind
of the Spirit because the Spirit
cue-2336
intercedes for the saints according to the
will of God. These
cue-2337
two intercessions are so united in purpose
and so perfectly in
cue-2338
harmony that they are truly one.
cue-2339
What is prayed by the intercessor on earth
is also prayed by the intercessor in
cue-2340
heaven. The Spirit takes the things of
Christ and shows them to us.
cue-2341
He takes the deep things of God and makes
them known to us.
cue-2342
He knows the purpose of God and intercedes
according to the divine will.
cue-2343
In this way,
cue-2344
He works in us both
cue-2345
the desire and the power to do what
pleases God.
cue-2346
The groaning that cannot be spoken belongs
to our weak humanity,
cue-2347
but the wordless groaning of the Spirit
within us is fully expressed through the
cue-2348
priestly ministry of Christ in heaven.
Intercession through
cue-2349
the Spirit requires a temple filled with
the Spirit.
cue-2350
He can only make spiritual things clear to
those who are spiritually minded
cue-2351
because the carnal mind can't understand
the mind of the Spirit.
cue-2352
He can't intercede in the heart of a will
that has not been yielded to
cue-2353
God. The pure in heart see God. The heart
must be open to
cue-2354
light and obedient to the heavenly
vision.
cue-2355
A person must be a saint to share in the
ministry of intercession.
cue-2356
There are many kinds of service that do
not require deep spirituality to succeed.
cue-2357
Preaching may become an art with no power
of the Spirit. Outward church ministry
cue-2358
may be carried on by the abilities of
office and routine alone.
cue-2359
Social service may produce good reports
without any warmth of spiritual life.
cue-2360
Church music may be of such a kind that it
does not require the burden and pain of
cue-2361
intercession.
cue-2362
The man of prayer must be a man of God.
cue-2363
The intercession of the secret place.
cue-2364
We are called to share in this twofold
intercession.
cue-2365
The words used to describe it show that it
requires sacrifice, hard labor, and
cue-2366
steady earnestness. Few things cost more.
Paul speaks of
cue-2367
travail, striving, and laboring in prayer.
cue-2368
Victorious intercession always carries
deep burden and suffering.
cue-2369
The reason is not that God is unwilling,
because when He inspires prayer,
cue-2370
it is because He intends to answer.
cue-2371
The struggle comes from many enemies in
the human will and also from spiritual
cue-2372
powers and forces.
cue-2373
God waits to bless, which means He is
always ready and always willing.
cue-2374
Daniel's prayer was delayed for three
weeks because of a hidden conflict in the
cue-2375
spiritual realm.
cue-2376
Paul says,
cue-2377
"Our wrestling is not against flesh and
blood, but against the principalities,
cue-2378
against the powers, against the world
rulers of this darkness, against the
cue-2379
spiritual hosts of wickedness in the
heavenly places."
cue-2380
Jesus said,
cue-2381
"Satan hath desired to have you that he
may sift you as wheat, but I have
cue-2382
prayed for thee."
cue-2383
For whom and for what should we pray?
cue-2384
The general answer is for everyone and for
everything.
cue-2385
But the truer answer is according to the
intercession of the Spirit and according
cue-2386
to the will of God.
cue-2387
Some people have a special claim on our
prayers, our families, our friends,
cue-2388
our fellow believers, our ministers, and
fellow workers,
cue-2389
those we work beside, those over us, and
all those we know to be in
cue-2390
need.
cue-2391
Intercessory prayer requires intelligence,
understanding, watchfulness,
cue-2392
sympathy, earnestness, and sacrifice.
cue-2393
It often also requires patient endurance
and faith.Sometimes the
cue-2394
answer comes at once, and sometimes it is
delayed.
cue-2395
The one truth on which faith rests is that
the answer does come.
cue-2396
The Spirit who gives assurance knows every
circumstance, and His assurances are
cue-2397
always yes and amen in Christ Jesus.
cue-2398
I have tried more to describe the holy
place of my own faith than to give rules
cue-2399
or list examples.
cue-2400
This subject fills all Scripture, and its
reach has no limits.
cue-2401
Its mysteries cannot be fully searched
out, but its certainties never
cue-2402
fail. Its blessings cannot be measured and
are beyond price.
cue-2403
Who can tell how much has entered into a
person's life through the prayers of
cue-2404
others?
cue-2405
Who can measure the work done by those
whose ministry is to labor in prayer for
cue-2406
others?
cue-2407
God's great need is for intercessors.
cue-2408
Ye that are the Lord's remembrances, take
ye no rest, and give him no rest
cue-2409
till he establish, and till he make
Jerusalem a praise in the earth.
cue-2410
He still saves through those who sigh and
cry.
cue-2411
Chapter fifteen:
cue-2412
Praying for divine healing.
cue-2413
The subject of divine healing is always on
my mind.
cue-2414
Weaknesses and sicknesses in the body have
kept it before me as a constant question
cue-2415
in my faith.
cue-2416
In pastoral work, it can't be avoided.
Sick people look with hope to the words of
cue-2417
the Apostle James about the prayer that
heals the sick,
cue-2418
and they ask for guidance.
cue-2419
Some are healed through the prayer of
faith.
cue-2420
If one is healed, why not another?
cue-2421
If some are healed, why not all?
cue-2422
I have searched the scriptures over and
over from beginning to end so that I might
cue-2423
understand the truth.
cue-2424
I have not found this subject easy to
answer.
cue-2425
The problem of divine healing.
cue-2426
There is such a thing as healing through
the prayer of faith.
cue-2427
Many trustworthy and godly people bear
witness to this truth.
cue-2428
It also seems that some are given the gift
of healing, and when they lay hands on
cue-2429
the sick, the sick recover.
cue-2430
I myself have been healed through the
prayer of faith.
cue-2431
In my ministry, God has also used me in
the healing of the sick.
cue-2432
But I have never prayed for healing except
when the sick strongly asked for it,
cue-2433
and I felt a clear leading from the Spirit
of God.
cue-2434
In other cases, I have been completely
helpless.
cue-2435
There have been people for whom I would
gladly have given my right hand if I could
cue-2436
have prayed them back to health,
cue-2437
but I had to watch them suffer and die.
cue-2438
Some have suffered deep mental anguish
because they sought healing and did not
cue-2439
receive it.
cue-2440
That has been my problem.
cue-2441
When I was still a young minister, one of
the church workers became seriously
cue-2442
ill. We claimed the promises of God, and
some of the finest
cue-2443
Christians I have ever known prayed
earnestly and in faith for his recovery.
cue-2444
We would not believe that faith could
fail,
cue-2445
but he died while we were still praying.
cue-2446
The shock to our faith was very great.
cue-2447
One of my own sisters was an invalid for
many years.
cue-2448
Well-meaning but mistaken believers
troubled her with the same kind of
cue-2449
arguments that Job's comforters used
against him.
cue-2450
Together we searched the scriptures and
sought the Lord, pleading with him to heal
cue-2451
her.
cue-2452
The Lord answered her in a vision and gave
her peace, but not healing.
cue-2453
I could give many more examples on both
sides, and perhaps others have been
cue-2454
troubled by the same questions.
cue-2455
Witnesses to divine healing.
cue-2456
There are many people who testify that the
Lord is our healer.
cue-2457
A few weeks ago, I was near Bishop
Auckland, where Pastor Jeffries had held a
cue-2458
mission some months earlier.
cue-2459
As we were leaving a house we had visited,
one woman in our group said to her sister
cue-2460
that she was sorry she had not brought
some special tablets for her. The sister
cue-2461
had suffered severe headaches for years,
and this was a new remedy she intended to
cue-2462
try.
cue-2463
She answered cheerfully,
cue-2464
"You need not bring them. I do not need
them anymore. The Lord healed me,
cue-2465
and I have not had even the slightest
pain since."
cue-2466
Her husband and children confirmed her
words by saying,
cue-2467
"She is a different woman."
cue-2468
There are many testimonies like this. The
most remarkable case of divine healing I
cue-2469
have known happened at the Southport
Convention.
cue-2470
The Reverend W. H. Tindall was president
of the convention.
cue-2471
Because of the strain of much speaking, he
had developed a disease of the throat.
cue-2472
For more than a year, he had not spoken
above a whisper, and even that caused
cue-2473
pain.
cue-2474
Specialists gave no hope of recovery.
cue-2475
At all the meetings, he was a sorrowful
and silent figure.
cue-2476
People prayed for him continually.
cue-2477
At the speaker's prayer meeting on Friday
morning, there was an unusual strength and
cue-2478
unity of faith.
cue-2479
No one could pray for anything except the
recovery of Mr. Tindall's voice.
cue-2480
Faith grew bold, forgot what seemed
impossible, and claimed the promise.
cue-2481
Dr. Ebenezer E. Jenkins was leading the
meeting.
cue-2482
When the rest of us rose from our knees,
Mr. Tindall remained kneeling.
cue-2483
Dr. Jenkins said,
cue-2484
"This is the most remarkable prayer
meeting I have ever known."
cue-2485
Then he placed his hand on the president's
head and declared, in the name of the
cue-2486
Lord, that before the convention ended, we
would hear Mr. Tindall speak in
cue-2487
the tent.That night, Mr. Tyndall spoke in
the tent for fifteen minutes
cue-2488
and was heard by twelve hundred people.
He continued to preach
cue-2489
without losing his voice for the rest of
his life.
cue-2490
I was there and saw and heard it myself,
and there are still living witnesses who
cue-2491
can confirm what I say.
cue-2492
The experience of E. Stanley Jones,
recorded in The Christ of the Indian
cue-2493
Road, is another striking example of God's
will and power to heal.
cue-2494
Just before the greatest missionary
opportunity of his life, he found himself
cue-2495
spiritually weak and physically worn out.
cue-2496
He wrote,
cue-2497
I saw that unless I got help from
somewhere,
cue-2498
I would have to give up my missionary
career, go back to America, and work on a
cue-2499
farm to try to regain my health.
cue-2500
It was one of the darkest hours.
cue-2501
At that time, he was in a meeting at
Lucknow.
cue-2502
While he was praying, and not especially
thinking about himself,
cue-2503
he seemed to hear a voice say,
cue-2504
Are you yourself ready for this work to
which I have called you?
cue-2505
He replied,
cue-2506
No, Lord, I am finished. I have come to
the end of my strength.
cue-2507
The voice answered,
cue-2508
If you will hand that over to me and stop
worrying about it, I will take care of it.
cue-2509
He answered at once,
cue-2510
Lord, I make that agreement here and now.
cue-2511
Then a great peace filled his heart and
spread through his whole being.
cue-2512
He knew the answer had come.
cue-2513
Abundant life had taken hold of him.
cue-2514
For days afterward, he hardly seemed aware
of having a body.
cue-2515
He worked through each day and far into
the night,
cue-2516
and when bedtime came, he wondered why he
should go to bed at all, because he felt
cue-2517
no tiredness.
cue-2518
He seemed filled with life, peace, rest,
and with Christ himself.
cue-2519
Nine of the most demanding years of his
life passed after that,
cue-2520
and the old trouble never returned.
cue-2521
He said he had never before enjoyed such
health.
cue-2522
It was as if he had found a new source of
life for body, mind, and spirit.
cue-2523
Life had been lifted to a permanently
higher level, and he had done nothing but
cue-2524
receive it.
cue-2525
The Reverend Andrew Murray had a very
similar experience.
cue-2526
After he was healed, he traveled widely
through Europe, America, and South Africa
cue-2527
for several years, preaching and speaking
every day with great power.
cue-2528
Yet later in life, when he became ill
again, he said to his daughter with great
cue-2529
tenderness,
cue-2530
My child,
cue-2531
I would so much like to hold evangelistic
meetings, but God does not see fit to
cue-2532
heal me.
cue-2533
What does Scripture say?
cue-2534
The teaching of Scripture is the final
authority on this subject,
cue-2535
as it is on every matter of faith and
life.
cue-2536
For me, the Bible has the last word. I
accept what it teaches, whether I fully
cue-2537
understand it or not.
cue-2538
Faith can wait.
cue-2539
It may be humbling to endure the pity of
those who speak confidently from science,
cue-2540
philosophy, learning, or psychology,
cue-2541
but Christ's yoke is easy when faith is
sure and humility is willing to
cue-2542
wait for God's time. When evolution and
revelation seem to
cue-2543
disagree, faith rests on revelation.
cue-2544
Yet the greater difficulty is not the
opposition of science or scholarship, but
cue-2545
the disagreements among believers
themselves.
cue-2546
Interpretations differ,
cue-2547
but instead of joining every argument, we
should seek to know the truth for
cue-2548
ourselves, as far as we are able.
cue-2549
There is no doubt that Scripture teaches
that the Lord is our healer.
cue-2550
This is one of the names by which he
reveals himself.
cue-2551
It is also clear that our Lord and Savior
treated healing as an essential part of
cue-2552
his ministry.
cue-2553
He was a physician who healed all kinds of
diseases without medicine. He
cue-2554
sent his apostles out to heal the sick.
cue-2555
The gift of healing was, and still is, one
of the gifts of the
cue-2556
Spirit. Healing was part of the ministry
of the apostles.
cue-2557
This gift has never been taken away from
the church.
cue-2558
In every age, there have been witnesses to
its power.
cue-2559
The promise in the Epistle of James still
stands for all time.
cue-2560
The prayer of faith shall save the sick,
and the Lord shall raise him up,
cue-2561
and if he have committed sins, they shall
be forgiven him.
cue-2562
The Bible connects sickness with Satan.
cue-2563
God did not create man to be sick.
Sickness entered with sin.
cue-2564
Jesus said that some sicknesses came from
the devil.
cue-2565
He said of one woman that Satan had bound
her for eighteen years.
cue-2566
In Acts 10.38, we read that
cue-2567
Jesus went about doing good and healing
all who were oppressed of the devil.
cue-2568
At the same time, Jesus rebuked those who
said that sickness and
cue-2569
suffering always come from personal sin.
cue-2570
He said,
cue-2571
Neither hath this man sinned nor his
parents that he should be born
cue-2572
blind.
cue-2573
Sickness and sin are connected in the work
of redemption and healing.
cue-2574
Matthew sees the healing ministry of our
Lord as the fulfillment of Isaiah's
cue-2575
prophecy.
cue-2576
He cast out the spirits with his word and
healed all that were sick, that it
cue-2577
might be fulfilled which was spoken by
Esaias the prophet, saying, Himself
cue-2578
took our infirmities and bare our
sicknesses.
cue-2579
He bore our sicknesses as he bore our
sins, because both were part of the
cue-2580
same burden.
cue-2581
This does not mean that sickness itself
was transferred to him, for as far as we
cue-2582
know, he was never sick.Rather, in deep
sympathy and at great
cue-2583
cost to himself in body and mind, he
lifted the burden and carried it
cue-2584
away. The sinless Christ bore our sins,
and the one who was never
cue-2585
sick bore our sicknesses.
cue-2586
When he healed the paralyzed man who was
lowered through the roof, he first dealt
cue-2587
with his sin.
cue-2588
To others whom he healed, he said that
they should sin no
cue-2589
more. The passage in James also connects
healing with
cue-2590
forgiveness.
cue-2591
Paul also writes in First Corinthians
eleven thirty-one to thirty-two of
cue-2592
sickness and even death coming from
spiritual wrongdoing.
cue-2593
Yet there is also sickness in which there
is no personal sin.
cue-2594
It may be true in a broad theological
sense that all sickness entered through
cue-2595
sin,
cue-2596
but in actual experience, there is a kind
of sickness that belongs to grace.
cue-2597
Scripture must explain scripture.
cue-2598
Job's suffering was of grace. It was for
the glory of God.
cue-2599
Paul's thorn in the flesh was not caused
by sin.
cue-2600
Satan used it, but God allowed it for the
glory of his grace.
cue-2601
Paul healed others, yet accepted his own
suffering as part of the
cue-2602
sufferings of Christ.
cue-2603
Epaphroditus was healed by the Lord.
cue-2604
Trophimus, however, Paul had to leave sick
at Miletus.
cue-2605
For Timothy's stomach troubles, Paul
advised a little wine.
cue-2606
And in his travels, Paul was accompanied
by Luke, the beloved physician.
cue-2607
I believe in divine healing.
cue-2608
I believe in the healing power that comes
through faith. Even apart from religion,
cue-2609
there is often health for the person who
lives by faith.
cue-2610
Much sickness has its roots in the mind as
well as in the body. But divine healing
cue-2611
is more than healing through faith alone.
cue-2612
It is not the same as hypnotism or
auto-suggestion.
cue-2613
The Lord himself is the healer, and faith
is placed in him.
cue-2614
The foundation of my faith is in him.
cue-2615
I trust his word, the redeeming work of
Christ, and the sanctifying power of his
cue-2616
Spirit, who gives life even to our mortal
bodies.
cue-2617
The chief concern is to know the will of
God.
cue-2618
Sickness may sometimes be a loving
correction for disobedience, and through
cue-2619
faith the cause may be removed, the sin
forgiven, and health restored.
cue-2620
But I am also bound to believe that
sickness may sometimes be within the will
cue-2621
of God for discipline, for the glory of
his grace, and for service
cue-2622
to Christ.
cue-2623
I am certain that divine healing is real
and that the gift of healing still
cue-2624
remains in the church,
cue-2625
waiting for the prayer of faith.
cue-2626
I am certain that many people are sick who
should never have become sick and who
cue-2627
could even now be healed.
cue-2628
I am certain that no life is so full of
health and light as the life of
cue-2629
joyful and obedient faith.
cue-2630
I am certain that I believe with all my
heart and mind in divine healing, even
cue-2631
though I myself am often unwell.
cue-2632
Chapter sixteen: The problem of unanswered
prayer.
cue-2633
It has been many years since I first wrote
about unanswered prayer.
cue-2634
The problem became very real to me when a
man we were praying for so earnestly and
cue-2635
confidently died while we were still
praying.
cue-2636
The shock was overwhelming.
cue-2637
It had never entered our minds that he
might die.
cue-2638
We had claimed the promise. We were
completely sure of God's Word.
cue-2639
I do not think my faith has ever been
tested more severely.
cue-2640
So we went back to the Word, and God gave
me a message that has brought comfort to
cue-2641
many people.
cue-2642
Through all the years since, it has
remained a strong support for my faith.
cue-2643
Many years have passed, but the truth
still stands.
cue-2644
Even if I must repeat myself somewhat,
cue-2645
I want to pass this message on to others.
cue-2646
The problem.
cue-2647
There can be no doubt that God answers
prayer. Scripture speaks very clearly
cue-2648
about this. Nothing could be more certain.
cue-2649
All people are commanded to pray at all
times, in all places, and for all
cue-2650
kinds of needs.
cue-2651
The Bible gives many assurances that
prayer is heard.
cue-2652
The promises are plain, and Scripture is
full of examples and encouragement.
cue-2653
Christ himself said, "Everyone that asketh
receiveth."
cue-2654
The promise is not limited by place, by
time, or by subject.
cue-2655
Everything that concerns us matters to God
and is a proper subject for prayer.
cue-2656
God does not separate our needs into
sacred and secular or spiritual and
cue-2657
material.
cue-2658
The one who taught us to pray for the
forgiveness of our sins also taught us to
cue-2659
say, "Give us this day our daily bread."
cue-2660
Yet as we study this subject, it becomes
clear that there are conditions and
cue-2661
limits.
cue-2662
Prayer has its laws. The promises that
seem unlimited are surrounded
cue-2663
by certain conditions.
cue-2664
We are commanded to pray for all people,
yet there were some for whom the prophet
cue-2665
was told not to pray. It is possible to
ask and not
cue-2666
receive.
cue-2667
Prayers without sincerity and faith cannot
be accepted. This is
cue-2668
plain enough. God looks at the heart, and
so do we.
cue-2669
No one grants requests when these simple
qualities are missing.
cue-2670
That sincerity must belong both to the
prayer and to the person praying.
cue-2671
Fine words are not prayer.
cue-2672
Are all sincere, earnest, believing
prayers offered by godly
cue-2673
people answered as they ask?Experience
says no.
cue-2674
I have seen a grieving mother cling to the
body of her child, refusing to believe
cue-2675
the child was dead.
cue-2676
She had prayed. God had promised. She had
believed. He always heard
cue-2677
prayer.
cue-2678
How then could her child die?
cue-2679
When at last the truth forced itself on
her troubled mind, her sorrow grew even
cue-2680
deeper at the thought that God had not
heard her. There are many such
cue-2681
moments of desperate faith. Is God angry,
as in the case of David,
cue-2682
even when there seems to be no such cause?
cue-2683
Could it be that He is indifferent?
cue-2684
Could it be that He does not know?
cue-2685
Has He forgotten?
cue-2686
With questions like these in mind, I
turned to my Bible,
cue-2687
and there I found the answer in three
representative cases.
cue-2688
Deuteronomy three, verses twenty-three
through twenty-five,
cue-2689
where Moses prayed that he might go over
into Canaan.
cue-2690
First Kings nineteen, verse four,
cue-2691
where Elijah prayed that he might die.
cue-2692
Second Corinthians twelve, verses eight
through nine,
cue-2693
where Paul prayed that his affliction
might be removed.
cue-2694
These three men hold an important place in
Scripture, and yet each of them was
cue-2695
denied his request. Their prayers are
representative cases,
cue-2696
and together they cover the whole problem.
cue-2697
Let us look at them one by one.
cue-2698
The prayer of Moses.
cue-2699
Moses prayed that he might be allowed to
finish his work.
cue-2700
He had taken it up at God's command.
cue-2701
For forty years he had cared for and led a
complaining and ungrateful people through
cue-2702
the wilderness.
cue-2703
Now the promised land was in sight.
cue-2704
What could be more natural than for him to
long to see his life's work brought to
cue-2705
completion?
cue-2706
And from every human point of view, he
seemed impossible to replace.
cue-2707
He would appear to be needed in Canaan
even more than in the wilderness.
cue-2708
Enemies still had to be driven out.
cue-2709
The nation's order had to be established,
and the people had to be settled in the
cue-2710
land.
cue-2711
If he left them now, it seemed as though
the work of forty years might fall apart.
cue-2712
Internal conflict might ruin the nation.
cue-2713
It is no wonder then that he prayed that
he might cross over. Yet in spite
cue-2714
of the people's need, in spite of his
faithful record, and in spite of his
cue-2715
earnest prayer,
cue-2716
he died.
cue-2717
He died with his work unfinished. He died
when he seemed to be needed
cue-2718
most.
cue-2719
He died with the hope of many years
finally within sight.
cue-2720
Is it not often like this? A person may
accept his life's work as a calling from
cue-2721
God.
cue-2722
He gives to it all he has, mind and body,
time and strength,
cue-2723
often at great cost to his own comfort and
personal hopes.
cue-2724
He prays for his work, asking God to
prosper it and bless him in it.
cue-2725
That is right.
cue-2726
No one should be engaged in work that he
cannot bring before God in prayer.
cue-2727
God does not place a person in work for
empty or unworthy purposes.
cue-2728
He intends work to have meaning and value.
cue-2729
And yet, how often it seems that the
prayers of good people fail.
cue-2730
Plans they have prayed over fall apart.
cue-2731
Competitors succeed. Trouble overtakes
them. Illness weakens them.
cue-2732
Death comes, and the labor of many years
is left
cue-2733
unfinished. At such times, death can seem
almost cruel.
cue-2734
It strikes just as the hand is reaching
for the reward. It takes the parent
cue-2735
or wise guide when they seem needed most.
cue-2736
It passes by the weak and takes the
strong.
cue-2737
It removes the one carrying the burden and
leaves the burden behind.
cue-2738
We plead to remain a little longer, just a
little longer, only until this work is
cue-2739
finished, only until the children are
grown, only until the business is settled.
cue-2740
But the answer may still be, "Get thee up
into the top of
cue-2741
Pisgah and die."
cue-2742
David wanted to build a house for God. His
heart was set on it.
cue-2743
God even praised him for desiring to do
it, yet he would not allow him to do it.
cue-2744
In the same way, many hearts are set on
some work for God with deep longing and
cue-2745
prayer.
cue-2746
Yet that work is withheld from them.
cue-2747
The man whom Jesus had wonderfully saved
begged that he might go with him,
cue-2748
but Jesus sent him home instead.
cue-2749
Juniper tree prayers.
cue-2750
Elijah was a mighty man of prayer.
cue-2751
God answered all his prayers except one,
cue-2752
the prayer that he might die.
cue-2753
He prayed this while sitting under the
juniper tree, worn down by mental and
cue-2754
physical exhaustion.
cue-2755
The day before had been a great victory.
cue-2756
He had stood alone as God's servant,
strong, bold, and triumphant.
cue-2757
But the next day was the day after the
battle.
cue-2758
At the threat of one woman,
cue-2759
he fled. His nerves were shattered.
cue-2760
Fear, discouragement, and despair took
hold of him.
cue-2761
In the bitterness and confusion of
depression, he prayed that he might die.
cue-2762
That condition is still with us, and
perhaps more common than ever.
cue-2763
There are not enough juniper trees for all
who would sit beneath them.
cue-2764
Some gloomy Christians seem almost to have
built their homes there. A
cue-2765
nervous breakdown is not only physical, it
is often spiritual as well,
cue-2766
though usually it is both.
cue-2767
Faith has no place for hopeless despair.
cue-2768
How merciful it is that God does not
always grant our words exactly as we speak
cue-2769
them.Few things dishonor God more than
the complaining hopelessness
cue-2770
of his people. Juniper trees make poor
places of worship.
cue-2771
The apostle's thorn in the flesh does not
need much discussion here because we have
cue-2772
already spoken of prayer and suffering.
cue-2773
The thorn was a bodily affliction, and
because Paul saw it as a hindrance, he
cue-2774
prayed that it might be taken away.
cue-2775
But it was not removed, even though he
pleaded with the Lord three times.
cue-2776
He had to learn that affliction may be a
messenger from God as well as something
cue-2777
Satan uses.
cue-2778
The answer to unanswered prayers.
cue-2779
None of these prayers went unanswered.
They were not granted, but they were
cue-2780
answered, and the answer was no.
cue-2781
No is just as much an answer as yes.
cue-2782
When a request is refused, it is answered
just as truly as when it is granted.
cue-2783
Sometimes refusal is the only answer that
love, wisdom, and truth can
cue-2784
give.
cue-2785
A child may cry for a razor, and grown
people may cry for things just as
cue-2786
unsuitable, dangerous, or unwise.
cue-2787
Many people have lived long enough to
thank God that he refused their desperate
cue-2788
prayers at some particular time
cue-2789
or for something that then seemed
absolutely necessary.
cue-2790
God never refuses without a reason.
cue-2791
He knows the past, and there may be things
in it that explain why a request
cue-2792
can't now be granted.
cue-2793
Sin may be forgiven, yet its effects may
still remain.
cue-2794
Moses and David were both examples of
this.
cue-2795
Some vessels are spoiled on the potter's
wheel, and though another vessel may be
cue-2796
made, the first one cannot be restored.
cue-2797
Diseases may be healed, but a lost limb
cannot be given back.
cue-2798
The Lord knows the future as well as the
past.
cue-2799
What seems good for the moment may put the
future in danger.
cue-2800
A craving for a single meal may cost a
person his inheritance.
cue-2801
Esau got the answer he wanted at mealtime.
cue-2802
Jacob received his answer at daybreak. God
added fifteen years to Hezekiah's
cue-2803
life, but in the end, it might have been
better if he had gone when the
cue-2804
Lord first called him.
cue-2805
The greater includes the lesser.
cue-2806
Delay is not denial, and it is always
worth waiting for God's time.
cue-2807
Moses did enter Canaan, and Elijah went to
heaven by a far more glorious
cue-2808
way than the one he imagined under the
juniper tree.
cue-2809
No prayer of faith that is truly inspired
by God is ever finally
cue-2810
refused. God's no is never his last word.
cue-2811
If a prayer seems unanswered, it is only
because the answer is hidden for a time in
cue-2812
a greater glory that will be seen later.
cue-2813
God may refuse one path because he knows a
better one. He brought Moses into
cue-2814
Canaan by a better way and in better
company.
cue-2815
I have known others who also had to go by
way of heaven to receive the answer
cue-2816
to their prayers.
cue-2817
God took Elijah to heaven in a much more
wonderful way than death in the ordinary
cue-2818
course.
cue-2819
Elijah wanted to die, but God gave his
weary servant sleep and
cue-2820
rest and then sent him away to the hills
for renewal.
cue-2821
That is often God's remedy for exhausted
nerves, fresh air, a new vision,
cue-2822
and a greater task.
cue-2823
Paul had no use for juniper trees.
cue-2824
To him, God said,
cue-2825
"My grace is sufficient for thee," and
taught him to rejoice even in suffering
cue-2826
and hardship.
cue-2827
In the experience that first tested our
faith so deeply,
cue-2828
God sent help out of the darkness.
cue-2829
Through the tears of a broken heart, light
came.
cue-2830
When the memorial card was prepared, it
carried these words, which corrected our
cue-2831
unbelief.
cue-2832
He asked life of thee, and thou gavest it
him, even length of days forever and
cue-2833
ever.
cue-2834
So one day in glory, we shall see that our
prayers were answered according to the
cue-2835
infinite wisdom and eternal love of God
our Father, who teaches us
cue-2836
to pray.
cue-2837
E. B. Browning wrote the following:
Unanswered yet.
cue-2838
The prayers your lips have pleaded in
agony of heart these many years.
cue-2839
Does faith begin to fail?
cue-2840
Is hope departing?
cue-2841
And think you all in vain those falling
tears?
cue-2842
Say not the Father hath not heard your
prayer.
cue-2843
You shall have your desire, sometime,
cue-2844
somewhere.
cue-2845
Unanswered yet?
cue-2846
Though when you first presented this one
petition at the Father's throne, it seemed
cue-2847
you could not wait the time of asking, so
urgent was the heart to make it known.
cue-2848
Though years have passed since then,
cue-2849
do not despair.
cue-2850
The Lord will answer you,
cue-2851
sometime,
cue-2852
somewhere. Unanswered yet.
cue-2853
Nay, do not say ungranted. Perhaps your
work is not wholly done.
cue-2854
The work began when first your prayer was
uttered, and God will finish what he has
cue-2855
begun.
cue-2856
If you will keep the incense burning
there, his glory you shall see,
cue-2857
sometime, somewhere.
cue-2858
Unanswered yet.
cue-2859
Faith cannot be unanswered. Her feet are
firmly planted on the rock. Amid the
cue-2860
wildest storms she stands undaunted, nor
quails before the loudest thunder
cue-2861
shock.
cue-2862
She knows omnipotence has heard her
prayer, and cries, "It shall be done,
cue-2863
sometime, somewhere."
cue-2864
You have finished listening to The Path of
Prayer by Samuel Chadwick.
cue-2865
Visit scrollreader.com to listen to more
free audiobooks.